[Music]
13 o clock hang out there happy holidays
it's our Christmas special we do this
every year you know is it it's card
because we kind of like run out of like
cool [ __ ] to talk about for the
Christmas special just the second year
no this is the third year because I
think the first year we did it before we
even had like you know visual a visual
component yeah we did like Christmas
creatures we talked about like Krampus
and you know the Christmas witch before
nobody's watched that one well you know
I think we were some real small channels
I had a good time uh last year Christmas
show last year I remember having guests
over some maybe now I can't even
remember this year what I couldn't
decide what to do for a really long time
and then I was like well I think what
we'll do is we'll do something like
something like we do with the
Thanksgiving show like a variety show
where it's like you talked about some
Christmas [ __ ] and like some Christmas
at Christmas adjacent kind of [ __ ]
that's horrible stuff and some horrible
stuff because that's how we roll I'll
save it for last so Italy so to leave
the show in a cheerful note like right
before because I think the show's gone
up on Christmas Eve unless you're a
patron in which case it will go up the
day before that
so you know you'll be left after you
listen to the show like really super
depressed for Christmas yay yeah
invented by the coca-cola company except
not and we're gonna get into that I'm
gonna get into that cuz that's like
something I always found really
fascinating like where the where the the
modern visual conception of Santa Claus
came from that's right and you know if
it's you know if this is the time where
you need to get on Netflix or and go
watch Christmas Chronicles with
cross-hole he just keeps plugging that
and I plug the crustle
I'm plugging the crustle oh yeah man as
though that's it that came out wrong
Russell's movie [ __ ] Christmas
Chronicles go back there
it's really good definitive Christmas
movies I had a good soul is like I like
just regular Christmas move I mean I'm
more into like Christmas horror movies
obviously because I'm just no well yeah
everybody's gonna die hard and Christmas
Chronicles right there I think yeah this
will probably be the ones that we
actually watch on Christmas Eve or
Christmas Day
yeah and cuz we already watch black
Christmas and I already watched like a
couple this like [ __ ] has some good
ones like better watch out and some
other ones I might watch those again
we'll see how it goes because like I
said I love I think Netflix is it
Netflix or shudder that has read
Christmas that is a sofa that is a [ __ ]
machine oh yes you have
oh yeah it's the one with with the
French one right no it's not the brezza
no we saw this we saw this one last year
remember it was the one about the guy
that came to the house and he turned out
to be like the not quite aborted fetus
oh yeah if you're easily offended you
probably don't want to watch it but I
thought it was yeah I remember I thought
it was really good is going and you got
and you got to see it's called red
Christmas I said you got to see somebody
get killed with a [ __ ] blender or
something like that yeah like there's
some really good kills in it but yeah so
that's what we'll be doing so like I
said we're gonna talk about like just a
variety of [ __ ] and depending on how
drunk we get then we'll see go be a long
show it probably will I'm gonna have to
like do it in parts just make sure like
exhibit rated [ __ ] like that we try to
do like put more Christmas [ __ ] in the
background but it's like oh the lights
that we had didn't work man we couldn't
like only part of the string lit up and
it wasn't long enough to like get got
him like Christmas tree huggers like 12
feet tall it's 12 feet it's so tall that
the top of it like you can't put a star
and I angel like nothing on top because
the top of it touches the ceiling
yeah but it goes together like that a
lot faster than the old what it's just
four segments to go together then it
opens up like an umbrellas got the
lights on already
yeah we're so [ __ ] yeah I got so
[ __ ] frustrated with the string of
lights man one bad light and it all the
whole things goes bad couldn't couldn't
keep those lights up and running but
these lights are built-in yeah yeah so
when these are the tree crosshole would
have when these go out you're [ __ ]
yeah you're gonna have to like
okay I thought they stopped doing that
with Christmas tree lights because
wasn't that like back in the old days
like when you know when I used to put up
the Christmas tree for my grandmother
like when I was a kid they had that too
it's like you buy like new lights every
year one they'd be all [ __ ] tangled
up until I was like anal retentive and I
was like wraparound cardboard I'd be
like see aren't you guys happy that I
made a retentive and did this for you
that was but yeah but it's like every
year you'd have to buy new ones yeah
they were cheap and show there's a
little like a buck or two for like a
string of them but I thought they had
fixed that now where it's like all the
whole [ __ ] string didn't go out of
one of the [ __ ] bulbs went out yeah I
mean that seems like a really easy thing
to I remember I remember back when I was
a kid a string of Lights actually had
glass bulbs on them that would actually
[ __ ] break sometimes there's like big
ones yeah they were big you weren't
actually supposed to put those on your
Christmas tree because you would burn
your house we did that [ __ ] anyway I
know we did too but you're not supposed
to I didn't realize that until later
until later it's like those are outside
lights you're not supposed to put about
the Christmas tree it'll burn your
[ __ ] out that this was the seventies
we do it we did whatever we wanted to we
burned our house like no one's gonna
tell us we can't my dad was sucking put
in the damn string of lightbulbs on I
was probably not six or seven and I saw
the one of them was broke and missing a
light bulb I've stuck my finger right in
that socket lit me up yeah it's about
six or seven dad saw me go flying and it
saw the look on my face what happened
and I was just sitting there going ah he
goes you get shocked and I went yeah I
saw another dashing back that back in
those days it just laughed
ya know yeah because like my little
brother my mom he's always tell the
story I have two brothers but my they're
both younger but my youngest one he was
born in 86 when he was a little kid yeah
he got the smart idea he found you
remember back in the old days where they
use well maybe they still have my don't
know but they used to have like those
prong things that you stuck in the end a
corn on the cob to make it like easier
to eat so you didn't get your fingers
dirty or whatever so apparently my
brother found that like in the kitchen
drawer and thought to himself this looks
like it will go right in an electrical
socket yeah it must be what this is for
it did go in there yeah and just like
you said he was like sure yeah and it's
like but my mom it's like she's very
funny because she was kind of just like
huh I mean this was her like her fourth
kid by this time so she was just like
over it she's like yeah whatever
but but she but she just like to say
she's like but he's really really smart
because because he likes saw that thing
and associate he's like oh that looks
exactly like that's what that should
know it's like she wouldn't think that
it went into the end of a [ __ ] corn
on the cob if you saw that it looked
like it would it looked like a plug yeah
so he stuck it in a library when he
learned not to do that again [ __ ] the
hard way it's [ __ ] awesome i
electrocuted myself one time not I
didn't stick anything in a socket I
don't think I ever did anything that
dumb but I was actually I was probably
like a little bit older I was like 11 or
12 and I had gone under the table to
like plug in a lamp and I guess that the
the lamp cord was frayed and I didn't
see it so I guess where my hand was like
so when I plugged it in I was like so
not only did it like throw me back but I
also like hit my head on the top of the
table so that was special yeah back in
the seventies growing up man with
parents used to smoke around the kids
they were smoking constantly yeah my
parents but my favorite [ __ ] smoking
one day one time my dad was lighting up
a [ __ ] cigarette he had that lighter
and I was a little kid and I just
assumed right in on that flame that's
the first time I guess I'd ever seen a
flame as I touch it like that and mom my
dad just held it there and then let me
let you drive it oh like that he was as
hot in it don't touch fire that's how
these teachers [ __ ] back then well you
know like I said if you burn yourself
but he wouldn't let you eat way he
wasn't gonna let me burn myself per se
let me find out like get close enough
don't touch fire and then I never
touched fire after that I was just
thinking of like damn it that's fire I
was just thinking of um goddamn it it
was a you guys remember that comedian
Paula Poundstone she was kind of big in
like the late 80s or early 90s and she
did this really one like this really
funny HBO special and I still remember
this one thing where she was talking
about cooking pop-tarts on the top rack
the oven and then she says in there
she's like she's like so I go in there
to get the pop-tarts that she's like and
you know in the oven she's like you know
that orange thing she's like you know
why that's harsh
yeah don't touch that she's like it's
very very hot it turns out so it's like
every time somebody talks about that I
always remember talking about what could
pick up the pot all right there aren't
thing in the oven yeah very hot as it
turns out all right but yeah I don't
remember do anything that dumb I did
other dumb [ __ ] when I was a kid but
yeah so yeah I know you did
we've heard all your stories about
chipping off the back of the house with
dip album covers stuck on my arms I know
a story how's it going flying off do you
remember what albums they were Frampton
Comes Alive not Jim Croce Oh Jim Croce
don't mess around with Jim yeah other
one was an Elton John record we sitting
at the black and we're sitting at the
piano yeah yeah yeah my dad had that one
yeah I remember him exactly that's
awesome I'm glad you remember I don't
think I remember to ask you before it's
records they've read about you you're
off how funny would it have been if it
was a wings album Paul McCartney how
awesome was that if you should Eliza
know what huh or fly like an eagle you
know I wouldn't who was that Steve
Miller Band er Elton John parish
approach oh well yeah what could have
been yeah alright so like I said on this
show we'll probably go
just like we don't know Thanksgiving
which I have a bunch of like Christmas
related [ __ ] to talk about but we might
go off on tangents Willis I don't know
we'll see how it goes hopefully this
isn't [ __ ] four hours long but you
know how we do like I said depending on
how much we drink it is look at this
[ __ ] okay so like I ran out of orange
juice and didn't realize it so I didn't
I was at [ __ ] we were at all day last
night I don't know why didn't buy more
orange juice because I'm stupid but uh
so this is actually it's kind of festive
it squadmate yes grenadine well then
brandy and vodka yeah that's good you
know so tropical it's tropical nuts all
ahead I was thinking maybe we should do
more Christmasy drinks but I don't think
we have any Christmas what for Celtic
time we have Christmas [ __ ] in the house
dog oh yeah you do know check yeah ain't
nothing wrong you got southern comfort
eggnog although well the see that's
weird because I thought when I looked in
the fridge and I was like Oh Southern
Comfort eggnog you would assume that
that would have alcohol in it but it
doesn't mention anywhere does not I
think it's just regular eggnog well yeah
I think if it has alcohol in it has to
say like that it yeah it would have
special name like whiskey flavor I think
it just it just says eggnog traditional
eggnog huh
so they just make regular old eggnog I
guess they do and then you have to just
by a brag euler old booze and mix them
together you'd a himself like some kind
of heathen yeah just buying it already
we're all together well yeah I'm not a
big egg nog fan I have to say yeah but
it's pretty good like I I can drink like
a little bit of it it's too much of it
is like too sickly sick that's what I
mean it's like a little I can't take
that much of it every cup oh you make
eggnog it's a cup of milk 1/2 a cup of
sugar and 2 eggs a little bit of vanilla
yeah that's it and you blend it then you
puts a little bit of nutmeg in it yeah
yeah which is you know it's like I said
it's good but I can only drink like you
know you basically like it's humbler I'm
basically talking about melted ice cream
yeah yeah I'm not a big fan of melted
ice cream either I like ice cream don't
get me wrong
but once it starts getting like kind of
watery I'm drinking melted ice cream
yeah see I don't like it that like it's
super for super frozen although I do
like soft-serve but that's really not
the same thing is it
eggnog ice cream is awesome just take
eggnog whip it get it real real cold
just like ice cream it did do it I would
think we're having another like
discussion that we're gonna gain like 30
pounds before that's before the end of
the show just like we did on
Thanksgiving one and what we're doing is
for Christmas because remember on the
Thanksgiving show we said that the
turkeys were so cheap that we went ahead
and bought two big like 28 22 pounds or
something like that so so we ate the
Thanksgiving one obviously that's gone
and so now we have the other one and the
other one is thawing so we're doing
pretty much Thanksgiving over again for
Christmas yeah it takes nearly a week to
thaw after five or six days it takes to
thaw in the fritter
I mean if you leave it out it only
probably takes like 12 hours only yeah
like 12 hours if you leave it on the
thing but we had it in the refrigerator
for yeah it's a couple days five days
yeah cuz I told you the other day I was
like look Christmas is only a week away
you might want to take that yeah so
we're basically I don't have a problem
with that Thanksgiving foods good man
mmm it's like I didn't I got a lot of it
cuz we had leftovers and [ __ ] but yeah
I'll be ready for it it goes things
viral ham but we got that turkey
Wednesday uh you know what uh we always
had that I mean we didn't usually have
turkey for Thanksgiving we were growing
up we usually had ham you know an other
[ __ ] but I I like spiral cut ham but I
would rather have Turkey yeah you know
what I mean
I put the glaze on that spiral cut just
kind of you know he's doing it like his
sexy void in my mind
[Laughter]
put it in the oven and cooking it you
know and on spiral in that thing yeah
yeah they're good wheels like I said
weeks ago whenever you're cutting that
bone out of the middle just take just
unloading just unload big old pieces of
ham unloading it off for the [ __ ]
plate bone and onto the plate oh yes
yeah like what like I said my dad side
of the family we always had a big spiral
cut ham because my grandma was really
into him my mom's side of the family
they would do a ham and a turkey yeah
and every now and then someone would get
crazy and do like something weird look
at doctor and goose or something but not
usually but so sometimes we had like
ducks there are a little well it's all
dark meat well I like dark meat but yeah
they are a little that's a little much I
don't like it but uh yeah so I'm looking
forward to heaven Thanksgiving Christmas
there your honey shaped - they're kind
of fun sorry ducks yeah
they're not like round and plump you
know it's like a chicken or a turkey
they're kind of these long things oh yes
chickens and turkeys aren't really
supposed to pee you're pregnant plump
it's just the ones that are well when
they raise them in farms they are
because they fatten the [ __ ] out of them
there lay their freakishly big American
the American the [ __ ] out of them yeah
it's like big they're like the
equivalent of like those huge fat people
you see in Walmart that can't even walk
and they have to get like the scooters
we have we have a company here in the
United States called Santa's and farms
it's in Mississippi yeah and they're
FEMA is I've heard yeah some of my
family is kind of connected with the
owners of the Sanderson farms and some
of the people that work up in the head
office down there Mississippi so we get
all the scuttlebutt look in Sanderson
farms tried to sell a bunch of chicken
to Russia Russia Russia saw this bottom
saw the chickens and sent them all back
they're like what the hell is these
chickens they're mutant
yeah these chickens are too big no
chicken could be that big they want well
they thought that there was something
wrong with them there is kind Okada but
still the latter roids well yeah because
I mean honestly we just buy we buy those
Pig big packs of like chicken breasts
from Sam's they're ridiculous I mean all
turkeys yeah like you take this book
it's like this yeah like the chicken
breast it's like the craziest thing
you've ever seen and they'll grow to
that size like in 12 days yeah and like
I said they can't even walk man their
legs like their leg it's shareable don't
break their legs just walk I mean I'll
still eat them because they're so big I
get so big so quickly it's funny I might
have mentioned this before maybe we were
talking about turkeys or chickens or
whatever but there was a on Mystery
Science Theater remember they they still
like those educational shorts and stuff
and they did one about chicken farming
and I think it was made in the late 40s
or late 50s I can't really remember
sometime around there and it's just
funny seeing I think it's called the
chicken of tomorrow and they were
comparing like the older chickens to
like the newer chickens and like both of
them look like scrawny little things
like it's like thanks to the chickens of
today I saw some I saw some British
people on their news whining and crying
about American chickens said they didn't
want it because it was coronated they're
all oh the chlorinated chicken we're not
they're talking about but they're
talking about the bleach bath and after
they [ __ ]
after they kill the chicken and get it
all all dressed out they dip the chicken
through a bunch of water that has
chlorine in it kind of like up well
they're trying to kill a lot of back
time like a swimming pool yeah and that
evidently freaked England out a lot
because they don't make anything you
know they don't make chicken they don't
have anything so they don't realize that
if you don't do that you'll [ __ ] die
that shit's carrying salmonella [ __ ]
that shit's nasty chickens are dirty and
those chicken plants are dirty and if
you don't do that by the time you'll
wrap it up in a container plastic and
put it out there on the shelf and two
days later that should it be rotten
you got it [ __ ] around you gotta
[ __ ] kill everything it's like I like
I can understand that you know that
people don't want to eat like a bunch of
horrible chemicals and stuff that's fine
but it's like in some ways chlorine no
it ain't no big deal well counter that
[ __ ] and well and in some ways you have
to kind of like it's kind of a trade-off
too because you have to you know you
have to kind of come to a balance
between like how much of the chemicals
game is or do you want like the natural
like bacteria which can also kill you
so I mean everything its nature nature
doesn't care about you nature wants to
kill you it doesn't want to kill you it
just will because it doesn't care about
you like I said it's indifferent so you
have to really kind of hit a happy
medium between it's like yeah I don't
want to [ __ ] swallow lie either but
it's like I also don't want to have
salmonella Wow
and you're not supposed to eat the
chicken right out of the package you got
to wash it before you [ __ ] cook it
but it's just a little bit of dumb pool
water really yeah it's all it is yeah
then he swallowed that [ __ ] anyway and
we were kids and we'll hurt you man I
stro up true I used to swim so much as a
kid like in a chlorinated pool that my
hair turned green yeah
my hair was green and like hard like
crusty it's like a long time it like get
rid of that you'll have some people say
well there's other ways to do it ya know
there isn't another way to do it in the
volume that the United States does it
nice this is a [ __ ] huge country it's
got a lot of mouths to feed we produce
more chickens in a day than the [ __ ]
rest of the world are producing a damn
month it is it is still kind of freaky
to see this like chicken breast though
like yams I mean they're like really
disturbing yes in the future I don't
think they'll be growing chickens
they'll just be growing pure chicken
meat cloned chicken meat they probably
cry and honestly it's like I know a lot
of people are weirded out by that but
it's like I'm not really bothered it's
like if you can grow I mean chemically
you know for atomically even it's the
same thing but you don't have to kill an
animal to do it which is nice so you
know growing chicken you're just growing
chicken meat yeah but it gets I would
rather have that then like have to
[ __ ] kill a bunch of cute little
animals what they'll do is they'll do it
they'll beat they'll be doing it in a
gigantic factory that's kind of like a
bio lab so it'll be more efficient you
wouldn't have to really feed them
anything and you don't need any lands to
do it you know yeah like I said I mean
they're already kind of doing that to
those [ __ ] check poor Chinese fish
where they just throw thousands of fish
eggs and a 50/50 gallon oil drum and put
the top on it and let those fish just
live in that drum and they try to get
out of that drum so they just keep
[ __ ] pouring drugs in there to keep
him sedated so they don't eat each other
yeah and they Justin so they don't move
but it's [ __ ] terrible when you think
I'm a official yeah this is a [ __ ]
robot but still it's still you know
that's not the damn fish be a fish yeah
but you know it's the that's they did
this fly and all that yeah I think
you're [ __ ] the Chinese have grown
them in a damn barrel yeah [ __ ] weird
when you think about it it's really
weird it is yeah it's just a barrel full
of [ __ ] fish just elbow to elbow or
Gilda Gil there their whole life and
then kill them all and then the process
of all all at the same time
yeah it's nothing I messed up I mean
like I said I don't know we'll see how
it goes I'm not I'm not super concerned
about like look if they can grow meat
that tastes exactly like meat in a petri
dish
I'll eat it I don't care it's like it's
like you don't have to you don't to kill
a cute little pig or whatever I'm all
for it
that's not why they care though that's
not why no I know that but it's like
that same money well you know [ __ ] but
it's like I'm just saying the reason
that I would do it I don't give a [ __ ]
about the reason they do it is you know
I mean you would eventually be able to
concentrate you grow a lot of them in a
short period of time in a small area
like I said it's constantly just be real
cheap that's some reason why you
wouldn't have to use a lot of land you
wouldn't have to like you know and then
here's another thing is that this is
gonna be poor people food really when
you think about it that's gonna be poor
people food rich people will still be
eating that [ __ ] on the hoof well yeah
of course they won't yeah just like
they're doing it now you just try to me
you just reminded me of it you just
reminded me of snowpiercer
was that where they were at where
they're eating those like weird gelatin
blocks and then like leaves roaches yeah
later they found out what they were made
from roaches which you know it's protein
and everything but it's like I can see
why you'd be upset about that I don't
want to eat roaches they're super dirty
yeah but yeah so alright so before we
get into talking about what we were kind
of talking about Christmas yet whatever
we have like several shoutouts this time
around lots of people to think this time
around
okay so we got Christmas PayPal
donations from Sandra or Sandra I don't
know how to pronounce it so thank you
very much also from Clara so thank you
guys like I said they sent us a
Christmas present over PayPal like
donations so thank you guys very much
for that we also have a new patron named
Rebecca we have one already called
Rebecca so we're just calling this one
Rebecca L cuz this is a different one so
Thank You Rebecca
and also we had a patron named fade who
increased their support this week so
thank you guys very very very much also
I would like to have a special shout out
to our friend and listener of the show
Sophie yeah who sent me the coolest ask
Christmas Rose check this out I cannot
wait until I get to read this this is
the gates of Janus the infamous book by
infamous Moore's murderer Ian Brady yep
where he is talking about other cereal
like he's giving his insight into other
serial killers and stuff like that this
this came out in 2000 Elector honest
I guess so this came out in 2001 and I
think this is like the new edition so
it's got like a bunch of different um
it's like a bunch of new stuff in it so
I'm like really super excited about
starting to read that because that is
like right in my wheelhouse and I really
want to say see what that [ __ ] has
to say for himself
what if he's gonna talk about the Curt
hit his own crime I would imagine yeah
but you know so okay so let's start
talking about oh I want to say too like
the first thing I want to talk about is
kind of like the tradition of Christmas
ghost stories and stuff like that and in
that vein I also wanted to do a shout
out that starting in the new year once a
week I'm probably going to start posting
you know me reading horror stories most
of them will probably be like old ones
like public domain some of them are
taken from like reddit like people that
have posted them and said they were ok
to read some of them are my stories also
and each one will have a theme it's like
it'll usually be like two three four
stories depending on how long they take
to read I'm trying to get them to be
about an hour you know I'm doing like a
werewolf one I'm doing like you know a
murderer's one or like a revenge murder
one I'm doing like all different ones
haunted hotels I think I did one of
those so that should be pretty cool and
also somebody asked in the YouTube
comments if I would read stories that
were submitted and yes I will so like I
said I can't promise you know when
they'll be done cuz I'm trying to put
them together and like themes and stuff
and I'm trying to get ahead so that I
don't have to do one every week
necessarily say I already have like six
or seven episodes recorded um so that I
can kind of get ahead and like have one
flick for every week I don't know what
day of the week I'm gonna put them up
maybe Wednesday or Thursday or something
like that but so that'll just be like a
new little thing for the new year if you
want to like listen to me read scary
stories then that'll be something that
you might want to look forward to
because that's something I'm gonna start
doing I'm calling it the witching hour
by the way yeah she's got a lot of
already recorded yeah I've got six
already recorded I have like one the
videos made but I haven't done the audio
yet well I've done a third of the audio
I just haven't done the other thing so
since we're talking about ghost stories
let's talk about
Christmas and ghost stories because that
very much used to be a thing and it's a
shame that it's not really that much of
a thing anymore in a way I feel like you
know now everybody tells scary stories
horror stories stuff like that around
Halloween which I guess makes sense now
because Halloween is like a way bigger
deal than it used to be but before
Halloween really became a big thing it
almost makes more sense for Christmas to
be the scary story time because you have
to think look the harvest is over it's
like the middle of winter everything is
dead I mean at least if you're in the
northern hemisphere and all the trees
are dead it's very cold everyone is kind
of like stuck inside you know sitting
around the fire and [ __ ] like that you
know it's the end of the year it's like
the shortest day of the year so it's
like you know a time when it seems kind
of natural for people to start thinking
about like the ends of things and you
know deaths and the circle of life and
all that other kind of crap so I so it
actually surprises me that it's not a
bigger deal like I think like the
biggest I mean it's been going on for
thousands of years but I think like the
kind of the biggest recent resurgence of
it was put like 19th century
you know the whole Christmas ghost story
thing and there's tons and tons of good
ones you know I've got a couple that I
could recommend obviously the most
popular one is Christmas Carol Charles
Dickens which came out in 1843 but even
before that and after that you know it
was like a big deal and Dickens even
went on later to like he was like an
editor on several magazines and every
Christmas they would put out these big
special editions at how these ghost
stories in him because that was a thing
that people very much did you know or
was you know sit around the fire telling
ghost stories on Christmas that was you
know a big tradition so it was so much a
thing that like even and I love this
quote I was like reading a bunch of
articles about this earlier and I found
this quote from 1891 there was like a
collection of Christmas ghost stories
that was called told after supper and
this was written by a humorist named
Jerome K Jerome which I guess that was
he's a humorist so I guess he's like
have the same name as first and last
name that's funny right other things
were funny back then that nowadays like
like what yeah I don't get it but um
yeah so he actually quoted and I believe
it was in kind of the introduction of
this book that nothing satisfies us on
Christmas Eve but to hear each other
tell authentic anecdotes about specters
it is a genial festive season and we
love to muse upon graves and dead bodies
and murders and blood I'm like that guy
he must have known me yeah really ahead
of his time so like I said so there's
even like mentions in like Shakespeare
and stuff like that about how winter is
like the best time for ghost stories and
all this other kind of stuff so now the
interesting thing though is that when a
Christmas carol came out in 1843 when it
was first published it was at this point
that Christmas was kind of on the
downturn a little bit because if you
remember prior to this Christmas back in
the you know Middle Ages and stuff like
that had been celebrated you know and
even before that had been celebrated
much like people celebrate it today was
like a time to like it drink a lot and
it was like eat a lot there was presents
and like a big partying like for several
days and you know people would like you
know slaves and masters would switch
places and it was kind of a time to like
get crazy and have parades and all this
other kind of [ __ ] but Oliver Cromwell
kind of put the kibosh on all of that
particularly in England so by the time
like the Industrial Revolution came
around Christmas was just seen as kind
of like it wasn't even really so kind of
a holiday but not really it's like most
people still worked on that day you know
it wasn't really a big deal a lot of
people didn't take the day off or
anything because you know when Oliver
Cromwell Cromwell had come along in the
17th century he was obviously a Puritan
and because Christmas was associated
with decadence because it was a time to
drink a lot and like overeat and party
and all this other kind of stuff so of
course he's a Puritan and they can't
have that so he made a lot of things
illegal you knows all of the kind of
festive trappings he made Christmas
carols it
legal you know no decorations no
anything like that so for a long time
kind of Christmas had been on the
decline
you know until Charles Dickens comes
kind of trying to like you know write
the story and sort of bring it back a
little bit but the tradition of ghost
stories went back you know much farther
than that least till the middle-age is
probably older than that what you look
like you were gonna say something Bert
oh now is it happened when a Christmas
carol came out this was also about the
same time like I said Christmas was kind
of you know a little bit on the down
swing but it was kind of like you know
it was kind of going through a little
minor resurgence so the christmas carol
comes out the first commercial was
commercially produced like christmas
cards also had kind of started to come
out around this time and businesses in
the 19th century right around the
industrial revolution we're looking to
kind of kickstart a new holiday around
that time period like to spur sales and
and whatnot so so christmas kind of
starts to come back a little bit and
kind of starts to turn into the thing
that we would recognize today and with
this came a resurgence in christmas
ghost stories so you've had a lot of
ones by like EF benson you had one spy
Algernon Blackwood and stuff like that
Algernon Blackwood I'm actually gonna
read some of his stories on my show and
then there were some like a little later
on and one that I really wanted to
recommend it you can read us in the
public domain so you can read it online
for free it's actually by AM barrage or
Burrage and it's called Smee and it's
set on Christmas Eve and it's about a
bunch of young people they're like at a
party in this big creepy old house where
a girl died like she didn't know her way
around the house and they were playing
hide-and-seek and she like opened a door
and she thought it was a room but it was
actually a staircase and she broke her
neck so then later on like all these
people in the house playing a variation
of hide-and-seek that's called Smee and
while they're like playing it in this
house it seems that there's an extra
person playing with them
and it's like a really good story it's
like really creepy I just reread it
again this afternoon before we did it so
that's one that I would recommend
there's also this isn't a pert this
isn't specifically a horror movie it's
kind of set around Christmas time but
it's a ghost story and it's very famous
by mr james who's probably one of the
most famous you know ghost story writers
in england you know from back then and
it's called a whistle and I'll come to
you my lad also a very awesome story
that you can read online and what ended
up happening with particularly in the UK
there was like a series between 1971 and
1978 that was called a ghost story for
Christmas and they would adapt it was
mostly mr.james stories and they would
adapt a bunch of ghost stories and like
show them like every Christmas time it
was like you know that you know a little
movie adaptation of all these old ghost
stories to show them around Christmas
because that was a big thing and it's
what gave them the idea to do that was
this 1968 adaptation of a whistle and
I'll come to you my lad which was like
proof so popular it was on a show called
omnibus and it proved so popular they
decided to like do ones like that every
year so it ran for like seven years and
then kind of fizzled out however I heard
that they have started doing them again
as of 2005 and so they'll show them like
I believe it's on BBC four they'll show
like Christmas horror stories I don't
know if it's just one or if they just do
one every year if they do several but
they mostly do mr.james stories and
along with some other ones and some
modern ones also they also did Charles
Dickens the signalman which is also a
really good story a lot of them are not
like specifically said at Christmas but
they're ghost stories that take place in
the wintertime and you know what I mean
it's that kind of thing now the
interesting thing that was that even
though that was kind of like a big thing
in England it didn't catch on as much in
the United States I feel like because
you know from the start of the u.s. like
you know with the Pilgrims and the
Puritans and all them coming over here
so
for a long time Christmas wasn't really
a thing because the Puritans didn't like
it and it's you know what I mean this
because of their religion and everything
so they didn't really like it
however you know when a Christmas carol
came out it kind of popularized it in
the United States as well but maybe a
writer like an American writer that
maybe had almost as much to do with it
was Washington Irving you know he's
obviously most famous for a legend to
Sleepy Hollow Rip Van Winkle and stuff
like that but he also wrote a [ __ ] ton
of Christmas stories and he seemed to
like really want to like kind of bring
because he had lived in England for a
while and he really wanted to bring like
all of these traditions of like English
Christmas like back to the United States
because it wasn't really a big thing
over here yes so funny that a lot of
these traditions that old boomers think
or anxious like things like Christmas
the NFL [ __ ] old just not old that's
all it's not yeah well yeah and that's
what I mean and I'm gonna talk about
Washington Irving like some more in a
little bit because he was one of the
people that was really kind of
instrumental in our more modern
conception of Santa Claus yeah but you
know he wrote so much stuff and like I
said Dickens you know starting in you
know the 1840s 1850s he had these two
like publications were like every year
they would put out this big special
edition that was like he had Christmas
stories in there there were like tons
and tons of other ones you know what I
mean so it was kind of like a big thing
and then because it was a big thing in
England like Washington Irving and a
couple other writers like popularized it
over here as well because they kind of
wanted it to catch on over here you know
but the thing about it though is that it
seems like I was reading something about
why a Christmas Carol in particular was
so iconic and why people still know the
story today they do like an adaptation
of it like every five minutes it was
like my base Tom memory my understanding
was
that was almost almost kind of like a
government effort to bring Christmas
into existence and wasn't that part of
it there was there was like political
backing behind that kind of not that I
ever heard of I remember um not really I
said well I think what I think the thing
that people responded to in a Christmas
story was not only was it like a creepy
gothic ghost story but it also had like
a nice like an uplifting moral to it you
know I mean because Scrooge was an
[ __ ] and it's like you know he kind
of learned his lesson at the end and so
I think that really kind of resonated
with people I remember something about
remember hearing something about back in
back in the 1800s there was a concerted
effort to kind of bring Christmas into
into existence it was something that
already existed but it wasn't something
that was normally like it wasn't a
holiday per se it took a while for I
think well hours to make that a holiday
yes there was kind of some corporate
backing behind it and that it was that
it was kind of linked with patriotism to
a certain extent okay trying to get
trying to bring a national identity to
the United States that's how I how I
remember I'm not yeah I'm not like I've
read a lot of stuff and I've never
really seen that it really does seem
like I mean there were a lot of writers
that liked it and you know they kind of
popularized it in their own publications
you know and there were some you know
there were businesses that wanted it
because you know obviously it would spur
more sales for them but I feel like I
don't know if it was like any kind of I
think it was just like a bunch of things
happening at once you know anyway
there's a lot of stuff in American
common culture that exists today that
people feel is very patriotic and very
traditional but if you kind of look back
into it it's not very old
I mentioned the NFL the NFL the National
Football League seems like it seems like
it's something America has always had
you know I mean it has yet but actually
it has it it's it's not that old I mean
my dad's generation was big into that
but that is not a that is not a
football American football is not that
old as well it's only what like early
20th century man yeah I mean I've never
seen I had a black-and-white photo
actually just more kind of like brown a
tan and brown remember those old photos
it was they were more like tan brown
well like sepia tone sepia tone yeah
happy time of my grandfather in Laurel
Mississippi on the football team and he
was a little bitty did probably five
foot two okay and the uniform they wore
and the rules and the the ball it didn't
look anything like American football no
nothing like it and they weren't big
guys I asked my lesson today what sport
is that he goes that's football
and I was like the 30s yeah it's like
the back of the thirties is this
football well like I said well any you
know helmets American football is very
much based on rugby yeah but like a less
rough version right and well I saw the
photo might of mine you know my granddad
and his Union didn't even have a
football helmet it was just like a
leather cap yeah they just had like it's
had like flat almost like a aviator cap
arm it kind of roomy and then maybe you
drive a tank in yeah and it kind of
covered like ear flaps yeah like air
flaps yeah yeah I'm saying what is that
because that's football yeah as a
wedding a football I recognized the
football that you would think today the
NFL type football that's that's pretty
[ __ ] recent and I think it's on its
way out in terms of popularity because
our generation doesn't really watch it
that much yeah and I don't think I don't
think Zoomers want anything to do with
those kind of old sports they're like
video games well yeah you can see why
video games are more an art in your size
right well you're it's immersive you're
not just why don't other people do
something yeah trying to live
vicariously through some dudes that you
have nothing I mean you could argue yeah
when you're playing a video game yeah
you just sitting around your ass too but
it's like you know what I mean at least
you're like involved yeah you're out
here you're making like your own story
yeah so yeah football you're just kind
of like watching other people in another
city living vicariously
and through these teams through doing
simulated combat between towns of the
cities then it gives a [ __ ] anymore yeah
I mean like people do but I think like
the younger generation they don't well
like I said I can see why I mean video
games are all you gotta do is look at
the money yeah are a lot more money
talks and [ __ ] walks and that
money's vanishing in the NFL people are
watching it but like I mean like you
were saying before you know our
Christmas and we were talking about this
a little bit on the Thanksgiving show
too because I think particularly in the
US you know particularly one generation
of the u.s. that thinks that you know
Thanksgiving has just been celebrated
you know unchanged since the pilgrims
got here and that's not the case it's
like it happened a couple times back
then in the 1600s and then like no one
really gave that much of a crap about it
and then like maybe right around the
time of the Civil War yeah like they
kind of started doing it again yeah a
lot of this [ __ ] is a kind of artificial
yeah I mean in this sense real but it's
it's a it's a marketing thing it has a
lot to do with marketing sales and and
this the thing that cracks me up to
about Christmas is that especially
people that like complain about you know
Christmas oh it's so commercialized we
should go back to the religious aspects
of Christmas it's like that's dumb
because wasn't really well that's what I
mean it's like it this [ __ ] the way we
celebrate Christmas now like presents
food drinking stuff like that that is
way more old than the religious stuff
that was added on later I mean if you go
all the way back to like super like old
like pagan kind of [ __ ] I mean winter
solstice and everything you know
Saturnalia like the ancient Romans and
everything like that it's like that's a
lot closer to what we do now than like
the religious stuff yeah if you go back
so we are going back to the roots of
Christmas it's just not the Ritz they
wanted I'm sympathetic to the Christians
it's just that the Christians kind of
[ __ ] take [ __ ] and they [ __ ] take
[ __ ] too far our traditional roots of
religious creek the traditional
religious roots of Christmas was to say
that Christmas was sacrilegious well
yeah that's the
like I said Christmas was at least like
it if you like I said look at Oliver
Quarles and when the Puritans first came
to the u.s. Christmas was they didn't it
was either illegal in some places or
they didn't celebrate it because it was
sacrilegious yeah because they saw it as
a pagan holiday which is basic which it
was yeah every single aspect of the
holiday the Christmas tree mistletoe all
of that [ __ ] that is all from old old
pagan [ __ ] most of the all of it most of
those holidays were pagan and the
Christians kind of adopted them well yes
and with Easter what is right with a
strand Halloween they just to cover them
up with a Christian veneer because they
knew people weren't gonna stop it yeah
so they just figured oh well we'll just
they adopted they retrofitted like back
to so you're really celebrating right
the birth of Jesus or you're really
something even that you know because
people were gonna celebrate it anyway so
they figured well we can just say it's
for this reason some Christian people
might be offended by that but you have
to understand it's true though it's true
and a lot of the things that Christians
do at are borrowed their power from
other religions and they're borrowed
from other traditions that's just the
way Christianity it so it doesn't mean
it's wrong yeah
Christianity is made up of many of mini
Western traditions they've just gotten
and the same income everything is like
that everything is like that and it's
like and we'll get into that too when we
talk about is pure when we talk about
Santa Claus to you because it's like
look it's like there's billions and
billions of people that have lived it's
like cultures are very complicated you
know things don't go on over a very long
time shame you know a very long time
things changed and evolved and stuff so
it's like there's nothing wrong with it
and honestly if people want to celebrate
Christmas or Hanukkah or Kwanzaa or
whatever whatever you want to however
you want to celebrate it just do that
it's like no one's I don't let anybody
tell you it's wrong or nothing like that
just you just do whatever the [ __ ] you
want it that's right if you want to be
super super super Christian and just go
back to the roots of Christianity just
become a Jew come back did you just
throw the Old Testament out and go to
extremes
throw the Old Testament out just go
straight it just goes straight Old
Testament get rid of the New Testament
that's the original that's og right
there
OTO G yeah so everything is a mixture
and everything a dot yeah and like I
said that's okay because everything is
like that so it's like you are never
gonna find a single thing particularly
it having to do with like human culture
any time ever
everything is evil but that is like just
the same as it was when it started
everything is evolving and I mean
Christianity evolved also all right
exactly so so like I was saying you know
the Christmas ghost story thing you know
I I've seen speculated that the reason
that a Christmas carol is still a
resident Christmas carol today is like I
said not only because it's like a creepy
ghost story which is always awesome and
everybody loves those but also because
it has like a really nice like uplifting
message like here's this [ __ ] and
these ghosts came and they change him
and he like became a better person and I
think like a lot of people could get
behind that they said the problem well
it's not a problem from my point of view
but from from a you know a cultural like
being memorable point of view I guess a
lot of the Christmas ghost stories that
came later even like something like
Henry James like the turn of the screw
which is not it's not a Christmas story
per se but the frame story is like you
know a bunch of people Christmas Eve
sitting around telling a ghost story and
then they tell the story turn of the
screw because a lot of ghost stories
back then were like frame stories that
where people sit around a fire telling a
ghost story you know that is just a
scary story but it doesn't have like an
uplifting morale or anything like that
so as there's a lot of the Christmas
ghost stories that came later didn't
have that sentimentality that morality
aspect to it and maybe that's why it's
not as well maybe turn of the screw is a
bad example because that's like a pretty
well remembering you know what we can
take weirdest let's go throw
Christianity in there to the oldest
gospel is just mark and Mark doesn't
have a resurrection scene or happy
ending either Jesus is crucified and
that's it the and the end no sequel but
yeah so so like I said even though the
ghost story thing is not really I guess
it's kind of coming back a little bit
cuz I have seen like some like podcasts
and [ __ ] like that that do like big
Christmas I mean there's like a lot of
Christmas
horror movies and you know the whole
Krampus thing like with the parades and
everything that's coming back in Europe
and everything so people are kind of
getting back to like the scary aspect of
Christmas which I'm all about that so
I'm very happy about it
but it kind of died down although as
early as the like early 20th century
there were still like some books that
came out like around Christmastime like
game books and stuff like things to do
around Christmas that still had like
ghost stories in them are like that
listed that is like a big thing that
people did on Christmas so let's talk a
little bit this is kind of like a
related topic let's talk a bit a little
bit about the origins of our modern
conception of Santa Claus because I
remember I don't remember what show it
was on but I remember you saying that
Santa Claus was the like the invention
of the coca-cola con and that is a very
common urban legend I didn't actually
say that well you said something like
that it made me think of it I said that
that motif yeah look that optical visual
style that we associate with Christmas
and Santa Claus the red suit the white
trim the [ __ ] mistletoe all you know
I mean - look my understanding was is
that it was the coca-cola company that
marketed that look know what never they
um
it well the thing about it is that like
fat Santa with the beard and them know
that that's right it's much older than
that okay I was a creation of the codes
no I might argue that the coca-cola
company might have popularized it maybe
they brought it into the mainstream but
I mean I I've seen and I and I'll put
some examples like when I talk about
them I'll put some examples in the show
I mean I have found illustrations of
Santa Claus from you know mid to late
1800s Early 1900s that look pretty much
exactly like a modern Sandwell coca-cola
fat guys oh no they didn't start doing
those ads until the 30s 1930s okay so
they pretty much just appropriated the
image of Santa that was already all
right pretty well as
I should tell these greenhorns these
Yankees these sucking British people
these [ __ ] Australians these dirty
Australians out and [ __ ] out in the
outback okay I love all you [ __ ]
explain something to you guys about
coca-cola all right coca-cola was a soft
drink that's what they used to call it
and it was something you got a saloon
and you could get it in any
english-speaking country eventually also
Dr Pepper okay I love dr. pepper I look
at that on the coat what this was as
bars knew what they were doing guys are
going then they start drinking to get
drunk and start slowing down
stop drinking they would stop drinking
imagine that because cuz they're getting
drunk yes you have at some point I guess
free soft drink on the house which would
be Coca Cola bars do that or dr. pepper
yeah and that [ __ ] had cocaine and they
would pep you right up yeah you sober up
so you'd buy more oh you'd buy more
alcohol yeah and it was the energy drink
of its day
I wish energy drinks came of cocaine and
instant energy yeah yeah give me a trip
maybe someday if they decided to
legalize yeah drugs again
yes really it's mine that's my
understanding though Nana spent you know
there's about as controversy the amount
of cocaine and it was very small yeah it
wasn't like poison like a whole box yeah
it wasn't like an equivalent to two it
was snorting the [ __ ] like you know it
evidently like you've heard a Jay
McInerney novel or something everything
it was eventually you know with the
advent of the [ __ ] Food and Drug
Administration and the outlaw of [ __ ]
cocaine they substituted with caffeine
yeah
and it was about an equivalent dose of
caffeine of what it was con it with the
cocaine and it was similar well that I
think the cocaine version probably sober
you up a lot better probably yeah
that's the same principle as like bars
like putting out all those like salty
bar snacks that's supposed to like make
you drink more yeah because you're not
drinking on an empty stomach so you
don't get sick well and also because the
salty stuff like dries your mouth a
dilemma that makes you thirsty that's
why there's two like nuts and pretzels
and [ __ ] like that yeah it's a good idea
it is what was I hope I said they
thought of everything
every bar they [ __ ] had that out
there I ended up [ __ ] running up a
huge tab yeah see it does work they know
what they're thinking up now if some
bars I don't know is I was always kind
of like some bars were really smart
they'd starts on like Egg McMuffins yeah
breakfast right there at the damn bar if
it was me cuz like I think this every
time because for some reason like when
when I get drunk and hungry I either
want eggs I want something egg based
like an Egg McMuffin and hash browns and
[ __ ] not so much bacon but like I
usually want to move with eggs in it
yeah
and so I always thought it's like I
always thought the most genius move
would be to like have a breakfast place
that just served breakfast all the time
like 24/7 and open it like right next to
a bar yeah you know like right next the
most popular bar you would make a
killing yeah I mean the place that's
like you know independent bar where we
go the place that makes a killing around
there is that pizza place that's like
right behind it and that's been there
for like [ __ ] 40 years that little
pizza place I'm just thinking about
those Australians down there with their
hot Christmas although we have hot
Christmas too cuz it's Florida Florida
sometimes it's cold but not usually any
Australians are out there you remember
Mad Max is [ __ ] Falcon a Ford Falcon
xB I wonder if Ford is making a Falcon
for Australia nowadays and what the
Falcon be a Mustang with a slightly
different tweaked body I would do it
bigger than [ __ ] if I was in charge of
Ford
I'm Sam I come up with a Falcon xB for
Australia and it's gonna be a mustang
mustang GT with slightly different
[ __ ] body on it I'd bring that back
pride sell it price sell in Australia a
bit I don't know what do you guys think
any Australians up here you weigh in on
this I don't have that [ __ ] looking just
as I don't know I don't have a dog in
how would I have that [ __ ] for the look
just like [ __ ] racket ass keys
[ __ ] interceptor rad ground effects
and a [ __ ] supercharger sticking out
of the hood yeah yeah modernized
modernized yeah now now I just thought
of like since we're talking about Santa
Claus I was just thinking of like a
Santa sleigh but made of his
receptor yeah like flying through the
air pulled boy pulled by reindeer except
the reindeer are made out of car parts
Christmas mad max [ __ ] man
now I want to see that so alright so
obviously you know the modern conception
of Santa Claus starts with an allegedly
real guy Saint Nicholas of Myra who
lived in from 272 343 AD in what is now
modern-day Demery Turkey now he was
known as the patron saint he's it you
know obviously because he's Santa Claus
peoples have a patron saint of children
however he was also the patron saint of
sailors the patron saint of merchants
archers repentant thieves not only it's
not the active thief not the actors you
put the one who felt bad acts criminal
also prostitutes yeah Brewers okay
they're putting [ __ ] these pawn
brokers Bob brokers all the same [ __ ]
and students aunts do so he was doing
like if he was wearing many hats was
Saint Nicholas as the patron saint of
all these different people not just
children um so so famously there was a
legend I don't know how true it was like
I said were legend that sprang up around
him that he would like secretly like
give people gifts and stuff like that
which is where the whole Saint Nick
thing came from and then he gets starts
getting called Sinterklaas you know like
in the Netherlands and stuff like that
which is where Santa Claus came from
however our more modern conception of
Santa Claus even though that's where the
roots of it were probably started to
take shape right around the early 19th
century now in 1804 there's this fella
named John pin [ __ ] pin [ __ ]
and he founded the New York Historical
Society in 1804 he was an antiquarian
philanthropist you know it's kind of a
business owner and stuff like that now
for whatever reason he was like super
one of his big heroes was the st.
Nicholas so he decided that he
like his mission in life was he was
going to make December 6th st. Nicholas
Day in New York and he wanted to make
st. Nicholas the patron saint of New
York as well as the patron saint of the
New York Historical Society and this was
like a big thing and he was just kept
going on and on about and he was like
writing [ __ ] things that he wanted
this day to be like set aside for Saint
Nicholas because he thought he was so
awesome now all of this talk about st.
Nick got the attention of the previously
mentioned very famous writer Washington
Irving now Washington Irving joined the
New York Historical Society in 1809 now
later that year he published his first
book which was called a history of New
York from the beginning of the world to
the end of the Dutch dynasty damn he
published it under a pseudonym Diedrich
Knickerbocker now this was actually even
though it was called a history of New
York this was actually not a history at
all but a satire full of a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah there was like it was just
like a funny like a satirical like
history like where he just made up stuff
the beginning of the world and yeah and
he basically what what he did was he
kind of like made this romantic version
of like New Amsterdam and he also like
talked about the Dutch founders of the
city in order to make fun of politicians
that were around during his time so he
was making fun of politicians by you
know very obviously like conflating them
with the Dutch founders of New Amsterdam
so an interesting thing that he did
though and this is actually pretty this
seems very modern what Washington Irving
did to promote this book and get it to
sell because this was his first book if
you remember what he did was he
basically said like his he wrote it in
her suit in him he started like going
under what would today be called sock
puppet accounts and he kept writing into
all these different newspapers saying
that Diedrich Knickerbocker and the guy
that wrote this book that was going to
come out had disappeared mysteriously
and that all that was left of him was
this manuscript
so like he kept like writing all these
letters under different names and it
worked like when the book came out
everyone was like oh man we got to find
out what happened to this guy it's like
they took it so seriously that like you
know all these people were like coming
for we going we should we look for this
guy it's like what the [ __ ] and they're
like trying to figure out like what
happened to him and everything like that
so it's like he's like he [ __ ] knew
what he was doing man so yeah so that
was kind of so it was like a big deal
when it came out now what's interesting
about this book is that it came out on
December 6th 1809 which again was the
day that you know pintar was trying to
get set aside as st. Nicholas Day and so
in this book he tells a story that
there's this guy named Commodore Olaf
Van Cortlandt who was a real guy
actually but not the version of it
that's in the book but it was actually a
real guy so he tells a story about this
guy who actually came to New Amsterdam
in 1637 and in the story he says that
Olaf he washes up is like in a shipwreck
like at the mouth of the Hudson River
and he falls asleep and has a dream in
which he sees Saint Nicholas riding over
the tops of the trees in a wagon that he
uses to bring presents to children not a
slave it away but yeah it became a
sleigh like shortly after but it was
like a wagon and he said he saw it
flying like over the trees like in this
guy's dream and he also in this story he
has the thing where Saint Nicholas like
he smokes a pipe and puts his finger
next to his nose which a lot of people
will recognize from twisting egg for
Christmas or a visit from st. Nicholas
which is a poem that came out a couple
years later and so and then he has him
like getting back in the wagon and like
flying off so that was kind of like the
first thing of like the flying sleigh
and all that kind of [ __ ] that was from
Washington Irving now the poem that came
out called a visit from st. Nicholas
more commonly today remembered as twas
the night before Christmas that came out
in 1823
now he took the whole pipe thing and
putting his finger aside of his nose
thing he took that from Washington
Irving but then he added the [ __ ] about
because when you were saying about him
being a fat guy well in a visit from st.
Nicholas he calls him
chubby yeah right he calls so he can't
end it like his belly shakes like a bowl
full of jelly and all that other kind of
stuff so he actually calls him fat
essentially in this poem which came out
in 1823 and like I said to Washington
Irving back at that poem by the way if
he didn't know was written by a Clement
to see more and has been obviously
published a lot later on like I said
Washington Irving went on much later to
write several other stories that had
like you know tons of Christmas stories
and seem to like really like Christmas
and he really wanted to bring a lot of
the like English traditions of Christmas
you know the tree the you know the big
meal the ghost stories everything like
that he wanted to bring that to you know
the United States now interestingly the
first there was a picture book that came
out in 1821 a couple years before that
poem and it was called Santa Claus sa n
te CLA us like all one word this book
was called the children's friend and it
was written by a guy named William Gilly
I don't know if he did the illustrations
also but there's and I have a photograph
of this all right that I'll put in the
show and this little Santa Claus he
doesn't have read on but he had it's I
don't know if it was just it might have
been read at some point it looks kind of
goldish yellowish but it might be kind
of faded this little guy is basically
sitting in a sleigh like a wagon II
looking sleigh and it's pulled by a
reindeer like just one not eight that
came later but he he has a little like a
little furry hat on just like you know
he looks essentially like the modern
Santa except his outfits like kind of
yellowish now is Claus does Claus is
that it another another version of Klaus
yeah well like ice yeah sort of okay
well like I said it's kind of like
centre class it's like st. Nicholas kind
of that's where it comes from my
understanding
in Japan they don't call him Santa Claus
because they they don't think it sounds
good like Claus like Sandy Claws Oh like
in Nightmare Before Christmas that's
what they Jack Skellington thought he
was
they call him Sandy Claws that's what
they that's what he thought that they I
don't think they call him Santa Claus in
Japan because they have another name for
him yeah I don't know actually if
anybody's been that's what I remember I
might be full of [ __ ] yeah maybe but
yeah there's so in this little picture
book that's you know the first one of
like picture book that was about him
he's had he's in his little sleigh and
he's got like a little reindeer and he
also has a stick in his right hand that
is to beat bad children because like
many many other countries not the u.s.
obviously but many other countries have
Santa has like an enforcer that goes
along with him you know in some
countries it's like black Peter it's
Krampus or it's somebody like that it's
like you know saying if you're good like
Santa will bring you toys but if you're
not good then yeah then his then bad cop
will come and like beat your ass or
Krampus in Krampus this case he'll
either beat your ass or he'll put you in
a sack and take you to hell or eat you
yeah so you know we need that though we
do it's like it's interesting how bleak
pretty much every other country has
something like that but we don't right
because I don't have the stick and the
carrot that's what I mean and well and
it seems like for a while we did have
that because now like I said in the u.s.
I don't think the Santa in the US has
ever had like kind of a bad guy
counterpart but for a while Santa was
had both carrot and stick like he'd have
years of coal yeah well he'd have like
the bag of toys but then he'd also have
a switch yeah so like he'd bring you
good [ __ ] like if you were good he'd
bring his [ __ ] but then like if you
weren't then he'd like kick you out
America is there gonna water that [ __ ]
down that's what I mean it's like it you
know the children that yeah yeah it's
like well dough they can't handle it
yeah that's dumb I don't like I don't
think it handle it they can every air
everywhere else in the world they can
handle it but somehow here we get I
don't know they were telling us Grimm
fairy tales but think we couldn't have
Krampus that's what I mean it's like why
cuz that Krampus is so awesome yeah on
and it's like and like I said they have
like summon and I'm gonna talk about one
of them later to called Hans trap yeah
you know that's kind of in the
french-german border region which is
another thing it's like a santa enforcer
that comes there and you know you better
not [ __ ] up or yeah here it's like
pretty much all that'll happen it's like
if you're bad either Santa won't leave
your [ __ ] or he'll put some coal in your
stocking yeah you switch or something oh
yeah so there so that was from 1821 was
that little guy now one of the earliest
depictions that I saw that looks pretty
much like recognizable as a modern Santa
was from 1838 and this was actually this
little illustration was done by a guy
named Robert Walter Weir and he's
basically he got the idea of doing like
the nose thing and the pipe and
everything like that from a visit to st.
Nicholas a visit from st. Nicholas but
it's basically like a fat guy in a red
outfit and he's by a fireplace like with
a bag and there's a little stocking
hanging from the you know mantel with
like [ __ ] in it like people not [ __ ] but
yeah what stuff and he's you know he's
got his little pipe in his little finger
and everything like that so that's 1838
so like I said this is almost a hundred
years before coca-cola started their bad
campaign okay
where there are Santa's that are
recognizable as modern Santa's
one of the crazier ones though I thought
this was kind of interesting I have a
picture of this one as well
so there was a very famous swedish
singer named Jenny Lind back in the mid
19th century
so in 1850 she tours the US and her
promoter was PT Barnum at the very
famous PT Barnum now force if for
whatever reason I don't know why like
because context is lost at this point
but to promote the tour he made this
like pamphlet that had and he had like
all this other like merch and stuff that
went along with this tour cuz they did
that [ __ ] back then say that's not new
but he had this pamphlet and there was
this drawing on it it said Santa Claus
on it on the top but the dude that's
like underneath does not look like Santa
Claus he basically looks like Paul
Revere like he has like a three-cornered
hat and
like kind of dancing and there's like a
little poem under there since I'm
dancing a jig I'm having a freak which I
thought was very a man I'm like having a
freak what is that but I guess so like
so so I don't know like what like he's
got a bag with presents and he talks
about how he comes down the chimney and
I don't know what this had to do with
the singer Jenny Lind what this had to
do with her tour maybe one Christmas
time and I also don't know why PT Barnum
would made this thing with like because
like I said there had been fairly modern
depictions of Santa Claus by 1850 but he
made him look like a little Santa Paul
Revere context I guess so but it's like
that's pretty much the weirdest what
I've seen from this time period all the
other ones looked recognizable right as
Santa Claus and not just st. Nicholas
either like some of us you know these
were like pretty modern looking Santa
Claus now probably though the guy that
is most responsible for our modern
conception of Santa Claus and maybe a
lot of people know this is Thomas Nast
he's a very famous illustrator he was
the guy that came up with the the
elephant for the Republican Party he was
a political cartoonist and starting in
1863 he did a series of illustrations
for Harper's Weekly magazine which had
like a bunch of Christmas you know you
know Santa Claus type illustrations they
had him doing like Santa doing all
different kinds of things and he did
like pre he pretty much did them every
year for like a very long time so he had
like Santa on a phone he had like Santa
and mother Goose racing each other
for some reason Santa bringing presents
to soldiers like in the Civil War all
that other kind of stuff and these
illustrations look very much like the
modern conception of Santa Claus he's
got the furry hats like the red outfit
and everything like that he's fat you
know so the thing is though it's like
every he didn't have like a lot of them
look modern but there wasn't a
consistent thing because some of the
illustrations like I said he did them
every year for like a really long time
so he's like their annual Christmas you
know edition or whatever some of them I
guess he took the
you know how in a visit from st.
Nicholas he calls him a right jolly old
elf so I guess he took the term elf
literally so he made him small so in
some of the illustrations Santa is like
littler than a kid right and in one
particular illustration that I found
this one the kids like it's two big kids
faces because like I'm describing it
because in case you're just listening to
the audio podcast and you can't see the
picture the picture that I'm going to
show but it's like two big kids face
like sleeping and then there's like a
little tiny Santa Claus and like all
these other kind of like Nursery Rhyme
characters like climbing all over the
kids heads and everything so some of the
Santa's were like really really small
but some of the Santa's he made them
like elf sized so he was like a gnome
kind of right which kind of ties in was
like some of the Scandinavian [ __ ] I'm
going to talk about later now so yes so
he so he kind of did a lot to you know
give us our kind of modern conception of
Santa Claus now I will say that some of
the most if you saw them today and you
didn't know what year they were from you
would think they were modern one of
these was from it was an advertisement
from a company called us confection
sugar plums and they were called Santa
Claus sugar plums and this was from I
believe it was 1886 and that Santa looks
just like a modern Santa yeah the little
red outfit and everything and also there
were two editions of a magazine called
puck one was from 1902 and one was from
1905 I think and I have both of them one
of them showed Santa and like this
pretty lady like making out kind of like
under mistletoe and then the other one
showed Santa with like two ladies so he
was like you know getting jiggy with it
like you did back in the 90s and these
look very very modern like I was
surprised when I saw them and I couldn't
believe like what year they were from
because they look almost exactly they're
really cool-looking they're like kind of
Art Nouveau style but they look exactly
like I mean it was fat Santa he had the
same outfit he's like
he's got the little rosy cheeks and
everything so it's exactly the same and
again like some of the other kind of
weirder ones I guess for a time like in
the early 19th century like the 1920s
and stuff I guess illustrators kind of
got sick of the sleigh for a little
while and because there was all this
like you know kind of everybody was kind
of getting into sci-fi and like all
these crazy like blimps and dirigibles
and stuff so I found this one
illustration that was from this magazine
called science and invention and it was
like an I'll show that one too but it's
like this little boy sleeping in a bed
like he's having a dream and in the
dream like there's a little Santa Claus
but that looks like a modern Santa Claus
except it's in black and white and he's
like in like a big like a Hindenburg so
they put him in like all these kind of
like flying machines with a while yeah
because it was like futuristic so there
was kind of like you know um you know
there was kind of a I deliver all this I
think for doing that I was going to
deliver all these gifts in a single
night he's gonna have a Zeppelin a
rocket sleigh rocket sleigh yeah so yeah
so that and you know there was some of
him with like a hot air balloon and [ __ ]
like that and so like I said this thing
about coca-cola inventing it now the
coca-cola company beginning in the 1930s
so so like I said the this conception of
Santa Claus it hadn't been I guess it
hadn't been exactly codified because
there was a couple different like
variations but not real I mean there
were a lot of illustrations of Santa
Claus that looked like the modern
conception of Santa Claus like easily
you know almost a hundred years before a
coca-cola started doing their very
famous ads um so what happened in the
1930s coke was looking for a way it's
like because I guess sales of coke were
slow during the wintertime because I
guess it was more people associated with
more of a summer or whatever so they
said okay we need something like some
kind of big campaign to like make people
buy coke during the winter time so they
hired this guy who was a commercial
illustrator and his name was Haddon
Sundblom and he
actually taking his inspiration the very
famous a visit from st. Nicholas poem
and he drew a whole series of ads
featuring Santa Claus doing various like
bringing kids coke for Christmas or you
know drinking coke on his route because
he was worn out or whatever and you know
very famously the and I don't even know
what this means but like the the [ __ ]
ad tag line was the pause that refreshes
like paws like pawed like not like
animal paws but you know what I mean
I was like the pause that broke what
does that mean hmm I don't get it 1930s
now wasn't that long ago come on now
what the [ __ ] are you talking like I get
like I get that it's kind of like maybe
like the KitKat like give me a break
type of thing this may be like a break
in your day she's like you're taking a
pause like drink a coke and it's like ah
that was refreshing and then you just go
back to whatever [ __ ] you were doing I
don't know it just seems like a weird
way of putting it I guess taking a boss
yeah but I mean obviously because people
wouldn't say it like that nowadays they
would say they would say more like take
a break or something like well they
pride and have break back then maybe not
didn't have that maybe that's not much
didn't have that word it's like I guess
the more I think about it makes sense
but it's still some breaks basically you
know right sounds like a very like
taking a pause yeah yeah so that so that
was probably now what people of art and
I think we're maybe the urban legend
comes about that coca-cola invented
Santa Claus was because they said well
maybe because newspapers were still
black and white you know they didn't
have any color comics or color
illustrations the papers magazines did
but newspapers that didn't you know they
didn't really have like a lot of color
you know movies or anything like that
you know so you know the movies were
black and white so they said it could be
that more people saw these coke ads and
that helped to kind of solidify the
image in people's minds because that was
like what they saw
most commonly but you know I don't think
it can be said in any meaningful sense
that the coca quote that coca-cola
invented that image of Santa because
even several years before those ads came
out
you know one there were other
advertisements there were other
illustrations that looked like our
modern conception of Santa Macola came
out with this in the 1930s 1930s yeah oh
that was well you have to understand
something 1930s was a time in the United
States a great demographic expansion
yeah and a great time of expansion you
know this is where you have start having
skyscrapers you start having theaters
you start having what you would call it
in the media yeah so it could be the
first time you have Santa Claus in full
living color all throughout the United
States all at the same time would have
been in the 30s so it could have been
coca-cola was the corporate force you
needed to have to kind of unveil make
that a widespread a national level
that's probably why that what why
they're saying that yeah so I think
that's where the legend came from it's
not so much that coca-cola invented that
look because that had been around for a
long time over Cola delivered that more
people saw it and I'll help to like
notify notified as what it was it in the
culture is that's what Santa was
supposed to arrive and in coca-cola was
vast
they were [ __ ] it was a vast empire
they were developed they were delivering
these glass bottles of coca-cola
everywhere to even little small towns in
the south which meant that they would
have been delivering full-color posters
yeah full-color merch you know what I
mean they had these big round metal
shields that they would put out for yeah
and gas stations that were colored so
probably the first time your average
putting a little podunk out in a little
town the first time they saw a
professional rendition full color
rendition of Santa Claus was then mahtim
had some difficult
yeah probably with their talk it's like
I said there were examples before that
and like I said I'll show them in the
show like a lot of magazine example but
maybe not as widespread because maybe
like out in the sticks no one was
reading Harper's Weekly or you know PUC
or whatever the magazines were that had
these illustrations in them
for the past you know several decades so
you know and there were a couple of
other like little variations in the
1930s coca-cola would would have been
nothing to [ __ ] with yeah they would
have been a vast corporate empire they
would have had the ability to deliver a
good Christmas advertising campaign well
they're the illustrations the sunblock
illustrations are very nice they're very
beautiful and probably what they're
talking about and like I said if you
look at him today it's you know clearly
that's where I and I can understand why
people thought that coca-cola was the
one that came up with that look they
didn't I mean he delivered yeah he was
just using what other people would come
up with it and I don't even think one
person even came up with it it was kind
of like it you know it was almost it was
like a syncretism type of thing where
it's kind of like oh they took a little
bit strike Christ yeah they took a
little bit from st. Nicholas they took a
little bit from the poem they took a
little bit from Washington Irving they
took a little bit from this and that in
the other and that's just kind of like
what came about makes sense because red
and white are Coca Cola's colors well
that's what they liked about it so they
would so Coca Cola logically would have
had a massive Christmas [ __ ]
advertising campaign yeah that's
probably what they're talking about
and like I said you know Santa was
wearing red before that like even
controller said that's our that's our
colors so it's like that's gonna go
together right now I did see like there
were some older ones like from maybe
there early 19th century a couple of
times that I saw like Santa was wearing
like green like the green man or
something like that but it most of the
illustrations I saw were actually pretty
modern he usually had red or some
variation of red or like a gold type of
color a couple of them had like red and
black and stuff like that but that you
would still recognize it as Santa Claus
you know what I mean so what wouldn't
you think about it it's a brown drink
it's carbonated it's kind of caramel
it's it's cool but it's refreshing
that's kind of a Christmas flavor yeah
think about it I guess you could say
that cuz tropical flavors are not
Christmas flavors well no it's always
something that's spicy yeah or something
that's candy like like
caramel or peppermint peppermint err
yeah so I could see why somebody in the
coca-cola corporation would see that fat
man in that red and white suit and go oh
we could piggyback a product right on
that well yeah especially because they
were looking for like a big campaign
Rock to happen around that time period
because there was like sales slump
during the winter not as many people
bought coke during wintertime you sell
Coca Cola as a traditional force it's
very American it's very European it's
kind of religious it's you know I mean
it's your duty to buy coca-cola yeah
buying coca-cola is unifying America
it's it's like a gift I think I have
like a I think I have a world war one
propaganda poster that saying on it too
yeah I have to find that I'm pretty sure
I've put that in my folder to put it
well you know America the United States
is a vast country and think how vast it
would would have seemed to be back in
the early 1900s
yeah and the ability to deliver a single
uniform product to every corner of the
American territory simultaneously would
be a unifying moment yeah today you take
that [ __ ] for granted but not back then
yeah I had to have a railroad yet to
have mass communication you had to have
theaters you know it's just funny how
much of that we take for granted we take
all that [ __ ] for granted because it's
just like obviously it's obvious that
you could put but no to supply America
simultaneously everywhere you have to be
a [ __ ] vast empire yeah it's almost
kind of like a demonstration of your
corporate power yeah to do that yeah
think about it
all those posters you have to print all
those bottles you have to make yeah you
have to deliver them everywhere yeah so
that's it's a huge undertaking it's a
huge honor even now it is it's a huge
and get it done and then the Americans
are seeing it no matter what town you go
to you see those same advertisements you
see those same bottles everybody knows
what that coca-cola tastes like it
always tastes the same every time you
open up that bottle that's like magic
yeah that's like in air walking on the
moon in
some ways when you think about it it's
like yeah you take it for granted
nowadays and it's like even when you
think about it nowadays like all the
[ __ ] that's involved yeah it's still
difficult but thinking about it back
then then how much of a bigger pain in
the ass but everything was a bigger pain
in the ass back then yeah I'm talking
about the 30s yeah when a lot of things
are still kind of semi handmade yeah you
have a first corporate product that can
be everywhere yes that's a big deal so
yeah that's a big deal so I could
understand why people think that maybe
yeah there's a leftover idea that maybe
coca-cola invented they invented it I
like I said I don't think I would I you
know I don't think I would argue the
point that they put maybe popularized it
widely like that image of Santa Claus
but they did not invent it and like I
said that's that's demonstrable fact
because like I said I found numerous
examples now 100 years before that I
wouldn't say popularized the image of
Santa Claus I think more like they kind
of corporatized yeah Santa Claus they
made it official yeah like this is what
he calls looks like yeah cuz we're the
coca-cola company and we said we're so
[ __ ] what they're doing is kind of
like the 1930s kind of like the 1930s
version a [ __ ] stepping foot on the
moon yeah you know this is McDonald's
hadn't even existed then
yeah they what are still the 50s days
yeah and then that was a big deal that a
single restaurant could be everywhere
and to get you the exact same exact Sam
food wherever
over and over no matter where you were
tasted exactly the same that's still
kind of freaks me yeah and that's part
of the selling of McDonald's is the
uniformity that is that you can trust
that it always tastes the [ __ ] same
yeah because it's like you can be a
Timbuktu and you're like going to
McDonald's on the shit's ASIS ain't the
same [ __ ] hamburger and it's that
comforting feeling yeah of like the
official hamburger even though it's not
great yeah it's just like the baseline
well that's the weird thing about ischl
I think we were talking about this a
little bit the other day it's like no
one's gonna argue that like McDonald's
is like gourmet food or nothing like
that but it's like every now and then
sometimes it's like you don't you just
want
that's like hamburger right it's like
it's not the best hamburger and
obviously you can make a better one at
your house you know probably anyone
could sometimes I just want a goddamn
big man but sometimes you just want that
well it's just like the same thing it's
like sometimes it's like I know they're
fish filet sandwich is kind of gross but
yeah you want that if you want that
particular one just grab a hot [ __ ]
tartar sauce on again heat it up a
little bit in the damn lettuce yeah and
that soft bun it's like I know it's
gross I taste the [ __ ] same you know
every now and then I want like some
chicken nuggets with like [ __ ] sweet
and sour sauces and it's kind of
comforting it's kind of comforting that
it's the same yeah so it imagine what
you're gonna get so to imagine probably
in the United States that first feeling
would have come from the coca-cola
company that it's always the same yeah
like it comes from heaven at all all the
bottles all the bottles are exactly the
same shape just open it and open it it's
exactly the same get because you're not
dealing with air-conditioning or
anything like that in those houses
hottest [ __ ] yeah and it's that damn
bottle that pretty ass bottle with all
the angles member how those glass
policies look and they were small yeah
they brought those back to a cent and
then they would be cold and you could
open it up and it would have exact same
fizzy taste yep so I would imagine
that's the first that's the first
sensation of kind of a homogeneity yeah
even that they have you could count on
it yeah it's like it came from another
another dimension and made yeah it's
like you know you never know what you're
gonna get a really nice rap shoot you
know a lot of that [ __ ] from the 30s and
you see it was kind of Sammy had made
was [ __ ] exquisitely made a lot of the
stuff that well yeah they know they're
doing you know it's and I can see that I
there's a time and a place for both
things like I said sometimes I want like
a good hamburger like a home in like one
you made yeah or you know that's really
good but then sometimes you just want a
Big Mac in it and you just want a
quarter pounder with cheese
it's like just specifically that you
wants out of that Styrofoam container
out of the yeah well it's not even
styrofoam is paper now well no now
they're like that paper cardboard
yeah paper cardboard oh wow they went to
paper and that seemed awful messy but
it's like I kind of like that little
recycle bomber they have now at DLT I
used to love that [ __ ] and then the qlt
I don't remember the qlt I do remember
mcdlt because I used to like that I was
like you like the hot stuff on one side
and hold on it seemed like to make
perfect sense to me and then like you
can put it together later so you weren't
getting like all that
cross-contamination with the cold in the
hot I'm still a huge fan of the [ __ ]
McRib a lot of people like that big rig
needs to be on there all the time
no because then everyone no one would
give a [ __ ] yeah it's the only one it's
a special occasion yeah I think well in
a way like I think that's one of the
smartest marketing decisions they ever
made was to like just make that a big
special thing because now every time
McRib is like on the menu everybody
loses their [ __ ] I lose my [ __ ] over a
big that's what I do see everyone does
they knew what they're doing and it's
like if it was on there all the time
everybody like they would eat it for a
while and then they'd be like man you
know this isn't really that good and
then they wouldn't sell anymore it's
like it only comes like once every two
years and I can't remember the last time
they make well it's like I don't really
like them so I like Magrib I don't know
I don't I don't like them but I'm not a
big barbecue person I don't really like
barbecue sauce and onions a lot but um I
can't I can't remember the last time the
McRib was onions and pickles I mean it's
like I don't I don't see a lot of
advertising and stuff but you'd think
that if that when the McRib is out I
mean they usually put it on all the
billboards and [ __ ] like on the sign
there's my [ __ ] over the shamrock shake
- I see that [ __ ] just [ __ ] lose it
did they still do the shamrock I haven't
seen a shamrock shake in a long time
they used to keep bringing that thing
back yeah it's kind of a mint shake is
that MIT is it meant kind of yes I think
it was kind of a minty blue or minty
green it's green
obviously into green shake I don't think
I ever had one camera I was always kind
of like I love mint but I always always
kind of like grossed out by them for
some reason I love a shamrock shake I
don't think I ever had one if I'm gonna
get a milkshake I'm going to Steak and
Shake man and get Rowan but you know
well there's just something it's just
like anything else gentlemen like
shamrock shake is not the best shake
yeah but it is a shamrock shake yeah
okay
and sometimes you just want that yeah
all right so we're going to you let me
see tell ya robot sounds great
yeah we should I have like so much more
[ __ ] that we can talk about we I might
take more than one break maybe yeah what
do we have hour and half okay yes so
yeah so I might take like several breaks
that we could put like extra kit like
Christmas kitty videos and [ __ ] like
that in there so we're gonna take a
break right now to refill drinks go to
the restroom go find our wayward cat and
various other things and when we come
back we're going to talk about all kind
of different stuff Scandinavian elves
the Hans trap and talk about some
terrible family massacres that happen on
Christmas it's so cheerful you guys yeah
cheerful time of the season so we'll be
back in just a couple of minutes hey
boogie you're under the tree yeah yeah
you being a Christmas cookie you don't
care yeah it's nice under there though
you can pretend you're outside all right
we're back after the break Tom refilled
his drink yeah what I'm drinking right
now of course is becoming all the rage
on Tom Ginny's movies that's my facebook
group Tom shitty movie Shi ddy movies
what this is is this is that summit
gridlock that's the stuff you get it all
day the all DS energy drink and gridlock
is kind of like their version of it's
kind of like Red Bull citrus yeah it's
it's kind of tastes a little bit like
Mountain Dew in a way but I'm using that
with Silver Tequila the splash alarm and
that's [ __ ] good it's only like a
dollar for a really big can yeah it's
like half that prick no more I heard the
price yeah one third the price of Red
Bull that's the first time we've been
like I'd been hearing about all day like
I know what Aldi is and I but I never I
don't think I've ever actually been to
one so we actually just went to one last
X we were just like you know we went to
the movies and we were just like kind of
[ __ ] around and grid rock comes down
green cants got green plus on it it
seems to be the least favorite like that
was the one
you like the most because it tastes like
citrus and you can mix it yeah the least
favorite one it's the one that all the
other that's the one you want for
tequila whether they're like 99 cents
for like a fairly large can the gas can
whereas the redbull was the cans like
this big yeah they want like 3 bucks for
that well yeah because what there's four
of them in a pack and the pedicles was
like eleven but eleven dollars it's some
ridiculous right yeah
too expensive well and and really rebel
so you know yeah
gridlock that green gridlock drink is
well the cans black and green coming
monster I guess it's a it's different
than Red Bull citrus similar but
different it's not quite as tart a
little bit sweeter but when you but I
think it tastes better I think it mixes
with silver tequila a little bit better
yeah yeah it did I'll try no okay she
doesn't like to get I don't like to kill
it but it's a yeah but it's like I think
this person might ever been an all day
seriously we wintered all day I think we
spent $29 and we got all kind of [ __ ] we
got it's like it I got like all kind of
yogurt I got like a big thing of apples
I got like a big thing in like Christmas
boughs yeah I got we got all kind of
stuff yeah kind of heads we got to we
got like 40 hash brown yeah [ __ ]
thing a frozen frozen patties for like 4
bucks I got like a dozen eggs for 99
cents per dozen yeah cuz I love eggs I
gotta have all the time yeah cuz I
always have like hard-boiled egg the
packaging is more effeminate looking
than American packaging American
packaging is like some other idiocracy
it's [ __ ] bright hey by the hey
dumbass looking for this all these
packages are all European it's also if
you want Nuttall subtle place subtle
colors and subtle very subtle subtle
mminton feminists like then we're not
trying to offend you yeah I mean so
we're gonna put a stout collars it's not
too much that I feel like um I mean I
don't know about nowadays but like I
remember when I was in the UK it's like
what I'm saying like British people the
British people I meant like they [ __ ]
loved Americans and they thought it was
like super you know they they loved me
and
they wanted to listen to me talk and
stuff even though that's really
self-conscious about it but they they do
have a perception or they did then of
like just Americans just being very loud
and just being just really loud and
obnoxious and what [ __ ] bright colors
- yeah and I think God extends to but
that's not true of everything because I
mean I design packaging you know for a
living but it depends on what it is on
what it is it depends on what it is
because a lot of times I mean a lot of
the stuff that I design packaging for
they are trying to appeal to a
particular demographic and if you're
trying to appeal to a particular
demographic they like you don't yeah you
don't necessarily want it to look like
Bronto you know I'm saying Amanda
because I have marks on it it's gotta
have flames on it it's gotta have
[ __ ] like concepts with flames in it
kitties on it it's gotta have like
titties they want to design yeah like
the ultimate man package it's just like
I don't even know what product it would
be for yeah but um yeah it would be like
some kind of energy drink or something
like that called like [ __ ] we're not
talking about natural boobs we're
talking about [ __ ] implants well yeah
it wouldn't be like talking about yeah
we're just like no so I'm just gonna
make it's gonna be like black and red
and then it's just gonna have it's gonna
have everything on it's gonna have like
an ak-47 it's gonna have like big fake
tits on it'll just be like stuck all
over it like that and then it'll be the
best selling product with the male
demographic don't overthink it in the
whole roastery of the universe telling
you people don't don't overthink this
when you start overthinking it you lose
money I did do I remember one package
that I did I
I remember one package that I did that
was for one of those like [ __ ]
remember that was kind of a big rage of
those like as seen on TV like those
metal hoses yeah you know I mean not
pocket hose but I designed a package for
that and like the guy was very specific
that he wanted to very be very doodly so
it's like
black red metallic letters with like you
know the italic so it looks like it's
bracing and all that kind of stuff so
there's like people are into that yeah
so this was like several years ago right
so we're in Walgreens yeah and right
right there by like the the checkout
yeah where they watch it's a box
and it says on it pocket hose yeah it's
a hose that [ __ ] like folds up that
wasn't the first thing that I thought
she shows it to me I'm like looks a
pocket hose not go away she said I got
like a medium let me check out girl
[ __ ] laughed her ass because we
weren't even really talking to her it's
just like it this is the conversations
that we have all the time because of
course I saw it and I thought it was
funny because cuz yeah I thought of dick
obviously she would and so I saw I was
like look Tom it's a pocket hose and he
immediately just it's like yeah that was
a long time ago it's like I don't I
still am not entirely sure what that is
what is a pocket hose I mean I know one
of those is a garden hose well I know
it's a girl but what is it fabric so it
was real long but you can you could
squish it down to push it down a spot
which which I one of them put in your
pocket any guys Dan if you are into that
and I got one and then you could just
whip it out pushing this [ __ ] out
[ __ ] expand and you whip people with it
yeah let's just starts flowing it
straightens out I have to say that
whoever named it that was a genius they
knew what they were doing they were fun
I mean I didn't buy it or anything but
it's like I noticed it they knew it dude
but you know it's funny okay tell me no
we did end up getting one river
I didn't buy well I didn't buy a bucket
I was what do you do I didn't buy a
pocket I wasn't out of that name but we
ended up with with with a garden hose it
was kind of like that yeah I didn't I
didn't buy it I was I didn't last long
last well this year the thing is I I
work for I'm not gonna say who it is but
I work for a client who there's an I
guess a lot of companies do this but
their particular and especially with
like as seen on tv products where you
know they they kind of all buy them from
the same manufacturer
and rename but they all like yeah they
they all want new boxes and new names
and stuff like that so it's the same
product essentially but it's sold under
a bunch of different names yeah
so I rebrand everything yeah so
basically what he would do is he would
send me a box like of the package and
he's like I'm selling this product but
under this name and I want like
different pictures and he would take
pictures and stuff like that to put on
the box yeah it all comes out of China
anyway like even have this in like
[ __ ] health food and like
bodybuilding stuff like just the other
day I bought some some generic creatine
and it comes in a [ __ ] packages it's
a nice package it's over that metallic
bag kinda like the ones you you do for
the [ __ ] the TV or for healing
butterfly it was like that but some
people get that stuff and they rebranded
and yeah they're rebranding it and
they're selling it for cheaper than you
would get if it was like a [ __ ]
designer brand and I bought like two
pounds [ __ ] creatine which is like a
year's worth of it it's just a
nutritional supplement and it said on it
pharmaceutical grade creatine and Jenny
you know I'm kind of dumbass you know
I'm not a spelling knots or anything I
just accepted that [ __ ] Jenny goes look
they misspelled pharmacist I immediately
said yeah and I was like what and I
didn't take it offense to it because I
understand what rebate rebranding is all
about because I do because I do it yeah
cuz she does it just like yeah but
[ __ ] didn't have spellcheck did they
it's like they have spellcheck they just
did did you say is it yes you know I've
done that too it's like you know what I
mean I don't usually miss Bell things
cuz like a I'm kind of but yeah I know
well I noticed it like immediately I
noticed people spelling mistakes like
immediately not I am a little bit yeah
well I try not to make spelling or
grammatical errors but I do sometimes
anyway like just if I'm not paying
attention but I try not to because I'm
like really really anal retentive about
that I don't know why but yeah so that
that and there's like no it sounds like
deceptive but it's not really it's just
like everyone gets the products from the
same it's a huge manufacturer yeah all
these [ __ ] products come out of these
factories and you just like package it
with your own those factory sell it to
other companies that market it yeah so
that's a lie it by the ton and then they
[ __ ] put it in different package they
even ask to can you put this in and or
that it to get certain flavors yeah it's
like it's not always not all just the
same across the board because it's like
I've heard like you can do that like you
know like with tea you can do it with
perfumes you can do it with cosmetics
you know you can say I do I want this in
it but not that you know I want this
color that color whatever and they'll
make it for it yeah and the factory will
make it for you and they don't have a
designer do the packaging you come up
with the name and the copy that you want
it is your product yeah it's
personalized to an extent but like I
said make it they did yeah they they
just made it to your specifications or
sometimes you know in the case of
another client that I work there it's
pretty much the same yet and errata
everything like it everything's like
that yeah there's not a lot of different
like between you you go down to the you
go to you buy some [ __ ] frosted
flakes from Kellogg's right well guess
what all those other cereals are made in
that goddamn same [ __ ] Factory it's
just that that factory executes
Kellogg's it executes all these other
types of [ __ ] cereals but some of
them are kind of like something you say
like you can go to all these and see an
off-brand like we saw an off-brand yeah
of Lucky Charms yeah they call it
something else well it was just called
on a very matter of stars and sham bars
and marshmallows marshmallows and I'm
looking at it and it's got a [ __ ]
dude who's kind of like a leprechaun on
it
guess what epic honor Jason yeah guess
what that was probably made the exact
same Factory and it's that exact same
[ __ ] even if they're not yeah it's like
I always hear shape and it's got a
different [ __ ] box
I always suspected that like the big
corporations that had you know the big
bucks it's like they would get made in
the good you know the good thing and
then there'd be like the basement
facility we're like all the sweepings
and stuff went were they still made kind
of the same stuff but that was like
where the shitty stuff from there that
wasn't good enough and like it fell down
at the bottom not always though because
I've bought some stuff that was like
genera or store-brand like looking for
get look at Publix a grocery store their
store brand yes better than our good and
are actually like better than a lot of
like name-brand stuff I have found
Publix ice cream
is better than almost there pretty much
every other major brand I think except
except maybe Breyers yeah but on par
yeah it's just as good as Breyers I
think and my favorite bran was Bluebell
Bluebell had [ __ ] really high
standards or in there they still do
their ice cubes really good but like you
put Bluebell up against [ __ ] Publix
store brand ice cream and it's pretty
close man both good the Publix one that
has like a Publix of you know Girl Scout
cookies in there that's all yes it's
really good yeah the course if you put
Mitch Girl Scout cookies and then Publix
makes ice makes frozen yogurt and
sherbert they have their own dairy where
they make anything they don't have a
name for it it's not like you know how
um like Sam's has like members choice or
members mark or whatever the their brand
name is Publix just sells everything
under Publix yeah it's just the Publix
precious stands on its own anything yes
so all their [ __ ] is good that's what I
mean so I think that's kind of why um
they don't feel the need to like name it
something else because it's like Publix
is a pretty well-regarded brand you know
in the Southeast United States so they
don't really feel the need to go oh well
you know it's it's our product but we'll
name it something else to kind of give
it one level of you can go on your
distance you can go in there and get a
big-ass jar of like safe Publix ketchup
yeah and it comes in a squeeze bottle
and everything just like hunts and Heinz
it would be like two or three dollars
cheaper and it's better yeah I really
it's either better or just on sailor or
Hind sir yes it's it's better or the
same I have no I have no qualms at all
about wanting anything that they cuz
they have a version of pretty much
everything you can buy in their stores
that they make and III can't remember a
single time when I bought something the
store brand that wasn't good yeah or
that wasn't Italy at least as good as
the neighbor ant or baby are plugged in
the [ __ ] out of public dollars and it's
like I'm gonna tell you what if you want
a good sub sub sandwich Publix deli they
have the best there's sandwiches are
they [ __ ] awesome like I said if you
live in the south you know I'm talking
yeah and particularly there that my
favorite is the roast beef on the multi
grow
yeah that multigrain bread man I love
that [ __ ] cuz I want one you got yeah
that's like five bucks five dollars in
some sense you'll get like a 20 inch
damn so their foot longs for
I think the foot longs are 629 is that
what it is it's a foot long if feels
like it's bigger well cuz they put a lot
you and your pocket hose pocket and all
that [ __ ] meat that they pack in that
goddamn it's better than okay you know
and I did time in Boston there's a lot
of good delis there a lot of good
sandwiches and you know they call them
grinders and [ __ ] yeah and no [ __ ]
Publix grocery store their deli inside
that grocery store some little best all
this [ __ ] from their deli is there in
New York better than Boston all their
fried chicken is good like you can get
fried chicken in the deli yes like all
their branded Publix pretty meters but
their subs are like amazing yeah their
subs are really good well I don't know
what it is I don't know what Orlando is
not a [ __ ] podunk town
all right [ __ ] all the rich people
from New York all have houses here this
is their [ __ ] vacation homes and [ __ ]
and I'm telling you I've been in New
York I've been I lived in Boston for
many years you can eat better in Orlando
than you can in New York or Boston for a
lot less it's like it's just [ __ ]
good here real good yeah there are like
a lot of different types of restaurants
maybe maybe not as many as there's just
somewhere New York like that but it's
getting like a lot better you can if you
drive around you can have some of the
best Indian foods in the restaurant
we've got some of the best Indian
restaurants in the [ __ ] country and
when you go there's nothing but the
Indian people eating at them you know
it's good yeah buffets are [ __ ] great
but definitely yeah I was gonna say like
yeah public sub sandwiches are good also
everything I've ever had from the Publix
bakery is good yeah like you know we get
birthday cakes from there pretty much
every arts that are like the size of a
dotted quarter yeah we just had one of
those doesn't always though that was
purpose oh yeah man that was delicious
[ __ ] good
was just in between like when we took a
break when I was yeah saving the file
and every single tart and caramel corn
and we're like snacking in between there
goes the diet we've been drinking well I
know yeah that's what that's no
bad thing but not only will drink and
make you fat but drinking also kind of
makes you likes you break your diet it
makes you hungry and it like makes you
lose your inhibitions and you're just
like man I wasn't pancakes yeah yeah
yeah give me over the next couple days I
got to start cooking up all that [ __ ]
know yeah like I said cornbread we're
doing the Thanksgiving part two electric
boogaloo we're doing for Christmas I'll
cook up cornbread to make the cornbread
stuffing
oh we're not cheating like like
Thanksgiving where we bought the [ __ ] in
the bag real cornbread just oh it's just
two of us man we have like so much [ __ ]
well make real cornbread this time oh
man I wasn't totally satisfied it was
okay find it yeah I didn't notice much
difference but I hadn't had any for like
a year or so ya know it wasn't quite as
good so I got the real cornbread mix
okay well that's maybe a jiffy cornbread
yeah but I'm gonna put real cornmeal
burn it prior to that's what I see so we
always had like several box of that
jiffy corn bread looks like in the
[ __ ] cupboard it makes good Stephan
it does actually
it's not good cornbread it's no it's not
it's um yeah I mean that's kind of a lot
of the times what we had growing up just
because it was easy it's cheap yeah and
cheap it's only what is it like [ __ ]
it might still only be eighty-nine cents
for like a little box like the mix but
that's that's mostly what we had real
Mississippi cornbread is like eating
sand it is it's very core very very very
dry if you don't live outside the south
the deep south like we came up in these
[ __ ] don't know what cornbread
is they know it they they're cornbread
is corn cake it's it's wheat yes and
it's light but cornbread court is like
or not really it's not really that sweet
cornbread is [ __ ] only about that
high about an inch and a half high it's
heavy and it's very dry and very coarse
and very gritty but that's just the real
thing you have to know what to eat that
with it crackles and crunches when you
eaten it well the thing about it is that
well it's one of those things where it's
like you have to grow up with it Elaine
otherwise if you come to it later you're
just kinda like what are you doing yeah
it's kind of like grits
it's like grits you have to [ __ ]
understand grits well and grits too it's
like even people in the south don't
necessarily eat grits
plain because just plain yes there's
nothing to it they're not good you have
we've gotta like put yeah fully load
that [ __ ] with cheese and [ __ ]
butter and bacon bacon yes right I Ord I
just liked it with like a [ __ ] ton of
butter in it
honestly rich are there any salt grits
are the reason for obesity and [ __ ]
claw rest for all problems and
everything in the south and diabetes
well because I mean even when I was
growing up it's like you pretty much
cooked everything in bacon fat we don't
do that anymore well but back when I was
growing up that yeah you always had like
a big jar of bacon fat next to like in
the kitchen and you cooked everything
you cooked your every morning he would
have fried eggs and you would cook him
and make him fat they cooked everything
my dad one of the reasons why they had
damn take his heart out and put all
those valves and then put it back put it
back in with the turkey neck with all
the turkey yes that from day one there
was big dick that in my dad's damn
bottle they put bacon fat in the [ __ ]
bottle yep so good for you yeah cuz it
makes you big makes it big and fat I
guess it's healthy make you healthy
that's what they used to think well yeah
because that I think this thing about it
was that because my grandmother kind of
had this mentality - my grandmother was
um she like I said she lucked out in the
genetic lottery like she could just eat
meat meat and not gain a pound she was
like wait maybe a hundred pounds like
her entire life and she was a little
bitty skinny thing but like she was one
of those people and a lot of the people
like Southern people that generation
were if you weren't like at least kind
of fat you weren't a little over they
thought there was something about like
why aren't you eating like you would eat
like one helping and they even really
want anymore it's you were full they'd
be like no eat are you sick yeah they
were just keep pushing food up if
southern people were slightly stocky and
a little bit overweight yeah women
tended to they were first of all some of
the most beautiful women in the United
States actually came from the south a
lot of these a lot of these types of
celebrities Hollywood celebrities that
you would see actually have kind of a
secret southern
background a lot of more southern but
southern women were actually some some
of the cutest women in the United States
and they were physically fit voluptuous
in general my dad's generation until
they got to about 35 then they were
[ __ ] heavy
then you pork out you started a new
portal catch-up for a little while yeah
there was a lot of South American people
that are like that too though and like
Mexican people because of their diet
yeah very heavy and pork fat yeah and
then they died they didn't live very
long like I said so that's the way it
was I mean if you're active when you're
young you can get away with it but lose
that metabolism changed as soon as I
mean I'd like I said I did not like out
it's like as soon as I hit puberty I
just started like gaining weight like a
lot it hurts constant battle it is it's
it's terrible but it's you know because
like I said that's my mom's side of the
family are all like that yeah um you
know none of them are like heavy heavy
but all of them are like you know a
little bit bigger and they and to lose
weight they always have to like
constantly they are constantly
constantly dieting and my mom was
constantly dying any was growing up I
always remember she was going to Weight
Watchers like everything and she would
like she would get kind of heavy and
then she'd be like oh my god and then
she got a Weight Watchers and she lose a
bunch of weight and then it would go
back on and it's like so it was like a
whole they tend to be a big-titty women
though southern girls tend to be [ __ ]
kind of big yeah but my female my female
roles my mom side like I said they're
all built similar to me yeah and they
all have like this the same kind of
problems like I said my dad's side of
the family my grandmother is very thin
like all the women were very thin even
though they were from Tennessee and they
ate everything in bacon fat and [ __ ]
moon pies and my grandma salted peanuts
inside this RC Cola my grandmother drank
Coca Cola and coffee and that was it she
did not drink water she did not drink
milk or juice or nothing it was like it
you know I mean she used to tease me
because I would just drink water and
she's Oh that'll rush her pipes yeah she
drank Coke every time she drank
something she drank Coke Mississippi and
she never got fat I remember lots of
fried chicken
yeah we ate a lot of fried
chicken I mean it's an African American
diet really yeah lots of fried chicken
lots of watermelon yeah I can cut the
corners of watermelon off
I still have water or tequila into it or
they would pour [ __ ] vodka yes vodkas
bad vodka or sometimes even [ __ ] Jack
Daniels into fancy also good the
watermelons and they eat it outside yep
and these are people a lot of times this
was underage they were doing it they
were kind of underage in the mixed crowd
doing it because things like laws didn't
matter who's gonna enforce that there
weren't any cops we're doing all kinds
of cool [ __ ] it was a different era yeah
I like that nobody really had a had that
much of a problem with contributing to
the debate
yeah you know what I mean well because
most kids drink it and be like wow they
didn't want that but you know what I
mean so they didn't really worry that
much about it yeah yeah laws didn't
matter from what I remember not really
no it's just it just seemed very like I
said I'll lay back yeah it wasn't so
much like neglectful or anything like
that it was just that that was something
that just wasn't thought about this is
seventies 70s and early 80s yeah you
were just kind of like you know you went
out to play and you were gone for many
many hours and you would go out and set
things on fire yes yes we play with
chainsaws shotguns so I shouldn't kill
anyone go get the shotgun yeah like I
said as long as you didn't kill anyone
Roy it was fine it was funny then the
dogs would be with you and the [ __ ]
the animals the animals and the dogs
would be with you we'd set fires out the
forest the swing through this almost for
a second I thought you were gonna say
you set fire to the dog no no no never
set fire to the dogs and then I was like
you better not be saying animal cruelty
didn't exist in the South that I knew
well it did but no nobody you knew did
it yeah that's that was I didn't know
anybody that's know that was on that
that would have been very Oh
no that was yeah back then if somebody
would have done that everyone dog know
he'd be killed
yeah to a dog or a cat No it sets you on
fire if you hurt somebody's dog rightful
dog were like children rightfully so
yeah well like in a way I think that's
better because I think that that
attitude is like a lot more widespread
nowadays like we were just watching
because somebody recommended and we'll
probably review this on the Matt nation
but we were just watching that Netflix
at that three part series don't [ __ ]
with cats about [ __ ] Luca man yada
who did the show we talked about money
crime show and I in a way like I love
that he before he'd even killed a person
like just because that [ __ ] put like
the videos up of him killing those
little kittens and immediately like
thousands of people inventors said that
we're gonna find this [ __ ] guy yeah
and they did and I was like man good for
you that's not like the one time the
Internet's used for good it's like it's
too bad somebody didn't find him and
shoot him in the face before he shot he
killed a person as far back as I could
remember
as far as Mississippi in the South when
pets were pets there was a clear
delineation between pet and game animal
but raccoons and possums were also pets
yeah I mean I mean you you could kind of
shoot those if you were on a hot but why
would you because it wasn't enough music
eat them they're not good unnecessary
killing of them cuz they're scavengers
you're a scavenger and also the raccoons
are just not a meat on them and they're
kind of cute and they do other things
they do like little people that are the
monkeys of Mississippi they have like
little people here and like they're kind
of like cake but they're like that 70s
Mississippi
looka manana there to set that [ __ ] on
fire like I said rightfully saying yeah
it's it's kind of a shame nobody knows
like what they felt but the thing about
it is like the people that found him
it's like you know they told the police
they're like hey might want to check
this guy out because probably he'll kill
a person yeah and they didn't do
anything and the police didn't do
anything and he did kill a person
they're like told you set in a [ __ ] on
fire or something that kind of goes back
to Mississippi 2 Mississippi culture you
know what I mean oh it's a form of
purification to set him up that's why
the Klan did it you know I mean [ __ ]
because setting something on fire was
too pure
fired well that goes way way way back
because it's a Christian type thing that
in a Luca man Yatta
what he did to those cats and he [ __ ]
did that Chinese guy they'd have set him
on fire back and back in the seventies
well yeah they might set him on fire
like I said and then nobody would have
said anything about it the cops would
have been there setting him on fire I
think if they would have done it now I
don't think anyone yeah yeah there's a
boy did they would have gave a whole
lecture they would have frickin
explained here where he went wrong and
then they would have doused him with
some kind of [ __ ] final material in
sedima bar yeah well like I said yeah I
don't believe cuz the whole time I was
watching that I was just maybe singing
hymns and [ __ ] and [ __ ] then that's
it that's how that's it what a
wigged-out
I mean like I said I'm not happy you
mentioned in the clan but it's like you
know because that's no we did that
because they yeah because they have that
because it was a Baptist thing of of
that purification by fire yeah you know
but that's why they did it and it's kind
of a universal mean yeah it's a purified
by fire well yeah that's the thing
because it's thought to like erase all
into a way it doesn't really but you
know what I mean well have that person
that would have raised some [ __ ] evil
and in that case if I can look I mean
yeah well yeah what I'm just saying like
affirm a physical saying your stamp what
it doesn't erase everything so let's
talk about elves you were talking about
elves yeah okay yeah okay so here's
something that I felt like I said we did
a show a couple Christmases ago about
Christmas like creatures but I didn't
like cover a lot of different ones and I
kind of found these interesting I guess
they're more like they kind of became
associated with Santa Claus and since
they're more like gnomes really but this
is from Scandinavian folklore and I
found this out a scandinavian folklore
site and i just thought this was
delightful so these little creatures now
in norway and i'm sure i'm pronouncing
this wrong but in norway they are called
Nissa or nisa and in sweden they are
called humpty but they're basically the
same thing they're like these little
these little guys cuts kind of like
gnomes it's like they're little bitty
people and they have like little beards
and they have like little pointy red
hats and what they are is they're kind
of like little domestic sprites and they
live in your house or on your farm and
they take care of your farm and they
take care of your house like they clean
up your house they take care of your
animals so like gremlins but the
reversible grandma kind of but they're
like little people right you know what I
mean
so though the word tomte means and like
I said I'm forgive me like any
Scandinavian people's if I'm pronouncing
this wrong I'm sure I am
tante means homestead man so he's a
little guy that lives in your house
Nissa it comes from the name Nils
which is actually the Scandinavian form
of Nicholas st. Nicholas is probably why
these little guys became associated with
Christmas later on so they're like I
said they take care of like the house
mostly like they kind of live in the bar
and they take care of the farm animals
they will work really hard but they do
not like anyone kind of like messing
with them like messing with them workers
like interfering with what they're doing
now they do all this sort of I was gonna
say out of the goodness of their hearts
but not really but they don't ask for
much from the people all they want from
the people whose houses and farms they
keep they want to be like respected and
trusted also on Christmas you have to
give them a bowl of Christmas porridge
or you'll grot because this is their
favorite thing however you can't just
give them any old bowl of Christmas
porridge it has to have butter on it and
if it doesn't have butter on it
you are in for a world of hurt got it
this butter on you got it I understand
the butter dynamic yeah we are not a
margarine house this house buys butter
by the pouch you can tell them jammies
salted Anna
yeah well cuz you need them for
different outlet master cases I love
butter yeah and don't let anybody butter
shame you butter is actually a lot more
healthy for you than margarine the whole
margarine [ __ ] and the butter being
dangerous I'm not long as you don't eat
whole stick on you know yeah you gotta
be reasonable about the whole butter is
bad for you type of deal was a margarine
sales tactic they're just trying to sell
you margarine that's yeah but but
there's nothing wrong with butter I
don't mind either one like I'll eat
margarine I will eat butter I even
sometimes get that I can't believe it's
not butter like Fabio used to sell that
just you know cow because it's a lot
lower calorie like cuz I'll just spray a
couple on my toast and it tastes like
butter but it's not like forty million
calories yeah but that's the only thing
with if I didn't have to worry about
calories I would just pretty much just
eat butter butter Evers a lot of cow at
all times it does sorry buddy but it is
well not it's delicious it will not clog
your arteries like people say pork fat
will yeah but there's a lot of
difference between pork fat and butter
yeah just make sure you drink some wine
or eat some peanuts and you know I mean
that every now and then that wine and
peanut wine and peanuts and that wine
with peanuts in it yeah it'll help it'll
help you kind of break down the
cholesterol and stuff in butter but but
butter is actually nice good for you
well yeah because look at see this is
something that's always mystified me
yeah and it perhaps any of you that have
grown up in France can let me know yeah
so in France I don't know like maybe
maybe there's a thing where it's like
you know I know in Europe they walk more
you know it's like the the portion sizes
are smaller that's a big thing because I
have had like Europeans like come visit
me and they'll go to a restaurant be
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this is enough
food for three people you know which it
is I mean even for me it's like too much
to eat and I am from here's a certain
mentality in the United States when it
comes to restaurants it's like if I'm
paying I want I want to all the food
we're exactly all the food you got in
this [ __ ] joint but it's not
fortunate because they want you to
come back they want you to feel you had
your money's worth that's yes and then
definitely has none do with health Yeah
right
and well and it's definitely more I mean
it's more than a normal person can eat
like a fat person like or somebody like
not necessarily a fat person because
like some skinny people continue to look
can eat like if you're a practiced
veteran of consumption that's a good way
of putting and you can eat a lot but I
mean I go like like yesterday we go to
like sometimes we go to you know koi wan
like the Chinese buffet because you know
it's a good deal um I can't eat a
shit-ton in there I'll eat a plate and
about a little bit more and then I'm
like okay I'm gonna barf I can't really
create a really anymore but and I tend
to stick to like protein things like I
like boiled shrimp I like like little
scallops in the shell I don't you know I
don't eat any rice I don't need any
noodles I don't eat anything like that
yeah I mostly just eat like meat things
and like vegetable thing yeah yeah
you're not good and a little bit of
wontons ooh Ginny and I go to the
[ __ ] Chinese buffet to steal as much
protein from the Chinese as we can I'll
go down there and try to eat as much
[ __ ] shrimp yeah there's like oiled
shrimp it's because it just Ashley
priest bodybuilder and [ __ ] Olympiad
he'll tell you the [ __ ] you can get a
clean meal out of a Chinese buffet if
you know what there's a lot to pick from
yeah if you there's a lot of fish there
there's a lot yeah I tend to stick with
seafood don't eat noodles and don't eat
rice yeah I don't eat the good [ __ ] and
you it's quite healthy for you
I basically stick with seafood or like
pepper steak or something it's just like
meat and mushrooms and lots of onions
and broccoli yeah stay away from rice I
don't eat any noodles underneath all
right I'll cheat now I'll eat a couple
em crab rangoon every now and then I'll
have one of those or a dumpling but I'll
just have one
yeah but I'm mostly like [ __ ] to hold
plates of boils from he does yeah that's
like two pounds he gives it like this is
how seasoned we are at this [ __ ] you go
to the you go to the setup you go get
you goat you get two plate two plates
one underneath you go underneath the
other one cuz then you can put the
shells on that one yeah you have to get
one or two things a cocktail sauce also
in lemons you have to get one or two
wedges of lemon one lemon to put on the
shrimp and the scallops and one or two
lemons to wash your hands afterwards so
they don't smell like shrimp for the
rest of the different the rest of the
does that acid will eat that shirt
smells right up
protip yeah if you're out eating boiled
shrimp you is I mean you can wash your
hands too but the lemon is like lemon is
much better than it's much better like
they do the lemon first and then go wash
your hands clean is that lemon juice in
your hands and rub it around and rub the
peel that's an old trick from like
[ __ ] that's all redneck [ __ ] yeah
well from a boil some when you do crab
boil then like you know crawdad off fish
and [ __ ] yeah everybody sprays like
let's put squeezes lemons all over their
hands rubs the rock up on your face even
if you got it up and so you don't stink
all day like yeah like fish so you don't
smell like the [ __ ] fish yep so like
I said pro tip don't work like if you're
gonna go eat shirt but the [ __ ] these
[ __ ] on howdy
so as I was saying these little gnomes
the little Nyssa and tomte they like the
porridge with the butter on it of course
now the funny thing about this is that
apparently there is a legend and the
legend is called when the Nyssa got no
butter on his Christmas porridge and the
legend goes that it was Christmas Eve
and the servant girl was gonna leave the
bowl of porridge out for the little
gnome guy and she thought she would be
funny well she did put butter but she
put it in the bottom of the bottom
instead of the top ok [ __ ] him over to
[ __ ] him over so she hits the but she
hides the butter at the bottom in a bowl
so then the Nyssa the little gnome he
sees there's no but he doesn't even like
[ __ ] he did he's a [ __ ] around he
looks at the bowl there's no butter on
the top
he's like I'm burning this [ __ ] down
yeah so he basically he goes into the
barn and kills their best cow god damn
then he comes back and he's like alright
well just that's how pissed I am and I'm
gonna eat the porridge anyway so then he
eats the porridge and he finds the
butter at the bottom yeah then what
happen and then he feels bad yes so he
goes to the neighbor's house and steals
their best cow and puts it in the box
that's European yes it sounds like so
he's just [ __ ] over the neighbor
apparently there's like a whole bunch of
different stories about these little
gnomes where it's like if you're like
nice to your little guy you're a little
gnome or whatever that's taking care of
your farm and stuff he will totally
steal from the neighbors for you because
there's another legend to where one
farmer was like he was really poor and
he couldn't afford to buy hay for his
animals but he's like well the animals
seem to be doing really well they're
like really fat and everything and then
he found out later that his little his
little Nissa or his little gnome was
stealing all the [ __ ] hay from the
neighbor and feeding it to his animals
yes these are more rowdy
these are morality tales from the hockey
motherland it's kind of like morality
but it's kind of a sideways morale it
definitely is because the first thing I
thought of and we know it yeah who wrote
that [ __ ] know it the first thing I
thought of was like one he probably
should've checked if there was butter in
the bottom of it before he went all like
vigilante anima yeah cuz he killed a cow
yeah baby but he felt responsible cos he
felt Benny [ __ ] steal steal from them
and bring it up but yeah I could
understand that
that's must be funny it is kind of fun
ideas must be funny yeah well I guess it
went if you're thinking about it in the
modern parlance then like the neighbors
are like NPC characters they're
non-player characters yeah so it's like
it doesn't matter if they lose a cow or
not and they didn't even have anything
to [ __ ] do with like with the butter
not being in their Corrections place if
I think the injustice is supposed to be
funny
I can see that I think it's what they're
talking about I thought it was well I
don't know he stole from and there you
go we're gonna hold on that makes it
right and then you're supposed to laugh
those gnomes yeah I think that's what
they're talking about
oh that makes it right yeah that makes
it right your [ __ ] Minds will [ __ ]
know first so it's like for some reason
I just found that and apparently like I
did like a Google search for like
tomte and like this and stuff like that
and apparently there's a [ __ ] ton of
people on Etsy and I don't think they're
all from Scandinavian countries either
that make little like stuffed little top
tea and stuff like that that you can
have in your house for Christmas and
they are adorable
yeah little like gnomes is that they
look kind of like well I mean this is
Santa obviously does it my grandma made
this but this this is Santa but they're
like this size and they look kind of
like that they have like a little face
like that a little beard like that and
like really big tall like red hat yeah
they're cute as [ __ ] I think I kind of
wanted one I don't think that they're
trying to pass it off as that it was
right I think they're just trying to
[ __ ] point out that the gnomes are
[ __ ] that's how the gnome it's
supposed to be funny kind of like a
genie story
I can't yeah I can get that they're
dicks
yeah you know and it's like you have to
like appease them and they're like
really they're kind of like um you know
Karen when she goes to Starbucks yeah
and you know you don't get her [ __ ]
order right like you put [ __ ] regular
milk in it and so soy milk and like you
don't put enough pumps in there and she
gets like all can I see your manager so
I kind of feel like that's kind of what
they're saying that I think it's a
warning basically that you have to do
everything exactly the way no Monts yeah
or nobody else won't [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
yeah and if it's not even you it would
be somebody else like your neighbor yeah
that's what they're talking about Nome
causing destruction just because the
butter was underneath the yeah and I
think you're supposed to laugh at it
okay it is funny [ __ ] you everybody [ __ ]
somebody else or others those damn know
they're so Trixie yeah for some reason I
was very charmed by the idea that all
you had to do to appease them was like
just be cool to them like hey you know
thanks for like cleaning up my [ __ ] and
like taking care my animals and stuff
but also all you had to do was like
every now and then just throw him some
porridge only it's got AI got butter on
though if you just get playing Poor's
they don't like that [ __ ] now
want the full [ __ ] boat man they will
they won't they want the butter expect
better and everything yeah it's like
what's funny is that they had no concept
of like salt wells no concept of sugar
well what is what about maple syrup what
the [ __ ] would they say about maybe it
was I was like what if you gave them a
bowl of like Quaker Oatmeal with apples
and cinnamon and that's right which is
clearly better with with some butter
then just porridge and butter I mean
[ __ ] you could put butter on that dude
yeah what would happen if much like in
modern American folklore where you leave
cookies for say what if you gave them
cookies yeah
would they not like that because they're
like now I'm more into the porridge
would they be like an old person that's
like they have to have everything the
way that they have to this is like
newfangled cookies I can't deal with it
right oh I think I owe you gold now
ain't bring it I'm not lovable still so
it's like this just like it there's so
many questions they came about from my
reading about these like creatures yeah
and just I don't know specifically just
like the porridge and the butter it's
like you think they would their
supernatural creatures presumably so
they could aim high they could get
better [ __ ] than that you know I mean
yeah well this we're like it's like a
Snickers bar at least or something
hot cocoa I don't know anything a pork
roast
[Music]
next on a list
let's talk about Hans trap now remember
this trap yeah we have a hold on more
Hans trot too sometimes known as that
they said Hans trap yeah yeah that's
right
Hans trap or Hans Trump that was like a
[ __ ] transsexual a trap it made my
passable transsexual that maybe that
might be a dumb idea
you think it's female but it's a trap
it's a trap there's a trap yeah just
like yeah just like odds is that right
yeah I guess
well this wasn't this guy's original
name now remember how I was talking
about earlier how a lot of cultures have
like Santa Claus or the the Christ child
or
kind-- or whoever comes to your house to
bring the presents on Christmas because
pretty much all the Western cultures
have that but most other cultures other
than the United States Santa's got like
I sent an enforcer some some places it's
Krampus you know some places it's they
have one live load it's like black Peter
they have like a bunch of other ones
that's kind of like bad cop two Santa's
good cop right so Hans trap is one of
those but the interesting thing about
this person is that this is based on a
real guy who actually lived now you know
some of the stuff like it in his early
life yeah that really happened they do
have records of this guy but some of the
stuff after that was like probably made
up and you know then he kind of just
went into legend but this was a real guy
now his name wasn't Hans Trapp
originally it kind of like evolved into
that later on as he kind of went on it's
a legend he was actually called Hans von
truth ax and he was a knight and marshal
of the ruler of the palette innate I
guess you would call it this was a
territory next to the Rhine which at the
time belonged to the Holy Roman Empire
now he died in around 1503 at the age of
53 so he was born of the 1400s pretty
much since he like came on to the public
scene um nobody really likes the
[ __ ] apparently he was kind of a
dick so he kind of had a reputation for
being a dick so 1480 he gets two castles
like the elector of the region gives him
two castles one of them was called gruff
and Don and one of them was called
Burwash Dean I guess I'm pronouncing
that right he moves into the bursting
one and then apparently him and the
reigning Catholic Church this is around
the you know the area like with the
French and German border so he him in
the Catholic Church kind of get into you
know a beef let's call it that
apparently the monastery that was right
around the castle where this guy lived
they used to own that castle and all the
stuff and and and some of the land
around it and they didn't think that the
elector had any right to sell it to this
[ __ ] so they were kind of pissed
off about it so so there was like a big
feud about that um the abbot goes to the
elector the elector says now I sold it
to the guy you know legally you guys
don't have anything you know about it
it's like and even then just to be a
dick apparently despite the abbot and
like the other monks at this monastery
is like well I'm just gonna sell this
Hans person like even more land so suck
it
so now after that Hans decides that I
guess to supply more water to his land
and his castle he decides to dam a river
that's like right there and the
monastery is like there you know what I
mean they presumably used the river also
now he dammed the river there was a
reservoir and the town and like where
the monastery was like their water
started drying up so they understandably
got a little pissed off they go to the
abbot but that wouldn't do anything so
but finally they could you know
everybody complained so much the Hans is
like fine you [ __ ] I'll just like
tear my dam down and then he tears the
dam down and floods the village you know
because like I said kind of a douche
so the abbot finally is like had enough
of this Hans dude he complains to the
Pope but the Pope didn't really do
anything he kind of just [ __ ] around
on it for about eight years then that
Pope either died or was say you know I
had his successor like his next pope so
the next pope bring says Hans von
Schwarz is like you to come to Rome we
got to talk to you Hans would not come
and instead he wrote a letter to the
Pope in which he apparently said some
pretty nasty things and he also said
that oh you know I used to believe in
God but you [ __ ] were such [ __ ]
to me like with all the dam and the
castle business and everything that I
don't believe anymore at which point the
Pope excommunicated him take that [ __ ]
out now
Hans actually lived in the castle for
another four years
and then died of natural causes I don't
want to be a Catholic anyway stop it is
a Baptist handle some snakes snakes
that's right
stop smacking that mackerels okay don't
worry about all that so he dies of
natural causes like a snake bites that
yeah I worry about surviving snake bites
okay so he dies of natural causes in as
I said 1503 two years later the Catholic
Church officially lifts his
excommunication but of course he was
dead at that point it didn't really
matter now at this point it seems that
this I mean you know obviously the guy
was a dick but as time went on like more
and more legend kind of became attached
to this real person and a whole bunch of
other like exaggerations like started
being piled on to him until he
eventually became like this Santa Claus
figure in this particular or you know
his Santa Claus enforcer figure like in
this particular region of the world so
later on the legend went that it wasn't
only that he had written this letter to
the Pope that said hey I used to believe
in God but now I'm an atheist cuz you
guys were so mean to me or whatever it
was that he said and got it
excommunicated that kind of got
exaggerated later into now he's a
Satanist he sacrificed animals to the
devil you know and all this other kind
of stuff then like so then the story
went that after he got excommunicated
even though in real life he stayed in
the castle where he lived and he just
died in there and everything was normal
the legend grew that he was a Satanist
he got excommunicated and then he got
exiled like out to this [ __ ] like
house like way out in the forest
somewhere then he started then he went
crazy from the isolation and because he
was insane like you do he started
wanting to eat people like you know I
mean yeah insanity equals cannibalism
yeah as everyone knows
and specifically he decided he wanted to
eat a little kid so story goes he starts
wandering around this farmer's field
like near this place where he lived out
in the middle of nowhere and he decided
that he was going to disguise himself as
a scarecrow and like he stuffed his
clothes full of hay and everything and
then he would like stand on the side of
the road and like wait for someone to
happen past that he could eat which I
don't know why this cracks me up but it
does yeah so so he stands in the field
pretending to be a scarecrow for several
days just like waiting for the right
most delicious person to wire by so a 10
year old boy a few days later happens to
wander past him close enough I guess
where he could grab him
Hans trap because that's what his name
had involved to at this point by the
time that this legend had come about
he's waiting there the little boy walks
past Hans jumps on him then he carries
him back to his lair killed him and
roasted him yeah now right before he was
gonna eat him though God struck him with
lightning and killed him why he didn't
do that before he killed the kid right I
don't know but God works in mysterious
ways
they say he waited till he was the kid
was cooked like and then he's like oh
well okay now I'll do it sorry [ __ ]
almost sounds like something could have
happened not the lightning strike well
like I said this way it was based on a
real guy but the real guy just got
excommunicated for relatively boring
reading a can but then they made him not
only a cannibal but they also made the
whole like he dressed up as a scarecrow
to get his victims which I don't know
where that detail came from but it's
delightful so so how now there are
differing theories about how this
particular horror story about the
Scarecrow and him eating the kid and
getting struck down by
by lightning there are a couple
different theories as to how this legend
became associated with Christmas because
it is because in this part of the world
you know when montaine gets Santa Claus
in that part of the world but it's like
Christ child or Christian or whatever
they call him so when he comes and
brings the presents like Hans trap is
behind him with the stick that's he's
gonna be just like Krampus pretty much
except he's a human so the story so
there's two like different theories
about how he got associated with
Christmas now one of these was that when
Hans trap got struck by lightning by God
for cooking the kid that st. Nicholas
also happened to be in the area and
since st. Nicholas as I said not only is
the patron saint of children but it's
also the patron saint of prostitutes and
also of unrepentant thieves not
cannibals though which would make more
sense with the story but apparently st.
Nicholas saw hot strips body which had
been struck by lightning so he's like
old smokin and smoldering and [ __ ] and
he said well this guy is dead but he you
know he deserves Redemption so the story
goes that st. Nicholas like took Hans
trapped with him along on his rounds
taking presents to good children like as
a Redemption arc like he's like hey you
come with me and be my wingman or number
two or whatever it is you know and we'll
like pay back your karma or whatever it
is for eatin that kid like you did even
though God could have stopped you but he
did not so that's one story about how he
got related and and the other story is a
lot more practical where it's just like
you know the the legend of Hans trap and
the legend of Saint Nicholas you know
becoming like the Santa Claus type
figure these were kind of both becoming
codified right around the same time
period and so they just kind of somehow
got merged together like stories like
that do so some people think that maybe
it happened like that but apparently as
I said this figure is still in the
Alsace
region which i think is how you
pronounce it like right around the also
lorraine like right around with the
french and german border so st. Nicholas
comes to your house bring in good
children toys and Hans trap is right
behind him giving you beatings and I
even have like I said there's like even
I found a woodcut of like and I don't
even know if it's Saint Nicholas it
looks more like a female angel but she's
coming in there with like hey hi
children and like some of the kids are
like that and then like in the window is
coming this dude with like a big [ __ ]
stick here he comes
so yeah like I said Santa's enforcer and
I think we didn't cover that on the
christmas creature show because he's not
really a creature he's a dude yeah so I
thought that was really interesting the
Hans trap the Scarecrow cannibal all
right so uh let's take another break
right now so I can save this part of the
file off because we're doing this in
chunks so we don't yeah so we don't lose
anything and then we come back in our
final segment of the show which is our
most cheerful and by that I mean our
least cheerful I'm going to talk about
three horrible horrible tragedies that
all happened at Christmas so we will
leave you with something like to think
about Christmas Eve so we'll be back in
just a few minutes she doesn't want me
to put the head on her I went to put the
head on her she went bad
should I smell some kind of meat all
right you want to see what the hat looks
like you want to see what the hat looks
like she's like oh no god damn it don't
you put that hat on me it was suck oh
it's Christmas Pookie we put it on
during the show and she didn't really
seem to care but it's like she doesn't
want to she's like yeah you [ __ ] off
yeah well she has like a red collar on
that's kind of festive oh yeah
all right I'll leave you alone I'm sorry
I'm sorry cookie
[Music]
all right and now we're on the final
segment of the Christmas special yeah we
got three cases now the super super
bummer is it yeah they were a bummer
then they just check out nosey is kind
of [ __ ] they that's why that's what I
mean that's why people tune into the
show it's like I couldn't just do like a
regular show like I like I'm interested
in all the kind of stuff about like
[ __ ] hot strapped and like the
origins of Santa Claus and stuff like
that but then I was just kind of like
what's the horrible [ __ ] that happened
on Christmas that's what I mean it's
like I can't I'm gonna call them
Clockers this is the kind of [ __ ]
Clockers like a clock that sounds like
it doesn't think I movie from the 90s
about computer hackers yeah you did yeah
okay but yeah so it's like leagues it's
like I love Christmas but I also have
you know a morbid side and a lot of you
do so you know so I looked up it's like
what's a horrible [ __ ] that happened on
Christmas and these but there was a lot
of things obviously because it's just a
day however these were the three that I
found the most compelling and the most
depressing but also the most fascinating
you know I mean yeah so the first of
these is known as the Italian Hall
disaster this happened in 1913 also
known as the 1913 massacre this happened
in kalameet Michigan on Christmas Eve of
1913 73 men women and children crushed
to death in a stampede when someone
falsely yelled fire at a Christmas party
no there is like a lot more going on in
this story and apparently I had never
heard of this but apparently it's quite
famous in the Michigan area and there's
a big memorial there Woody Guthrie wrote
a song about it and everything so the
background of the story was that there
was a mining company they're called
kalam and
a mining company or C&H mining company
it was the largest copper mining company
in that part of North West Michigan
now what was significant about that was
that one of the longest strikes to ever
happen in this part of the country
happened in this year in 1913 and this
strike included pretty much all of the
our most of the workers of these the CNH
mines because there were more than one
so so there was like a lot of the the
strike actually went on from 1913 into
like spring of 1914 but over the
Christmas season even though the strike
had been going on for five months there
was kind of like a little bit of you
know they kind of called a little bit of
a truce because it was the Christmas
season not exactly but it's Lee you know
with you know the it wasn't like at the
heat of it like it was now what ended up
happening was that on Christmas Eve a
bunch of the striking miners and their
families they went to the you know
Italian cultural hall or whatever for a
Christmas party that was apparently
sponsored by the ladies auxilary of the
Western Federation of miners so this
party took place and there was a picture
of it's not there anymore but the
there's pictures of the building the
second floor of the Calla met Italian
Hall now apparently there was only one
way up to the second floor and this was
a very steep stairway there was a fire
escape on one side of the building and
ladders down the back but they weren't
real clearly marked and you could only
get to them by climbing out the windows
now there were about 400 people in the
room at the height of the Christmas
party and someone yelled they don't know
who someone yelled fire even though
apparently there was no fire okay so
someone yelled fire understandably
everyone panicked and started brushing
for the one set of stairs what ended up
happening was that obviously because it
was only one way out and like I guess
people didn't know that you could like
climb out the window
like down the ladders and everything and
people didn't know they were there so
everyone kind of rushed for the
staircase and 73 people ended up getting
killed
this included 59 children they all got
like stampeded and stomped on and stuff
like that now the debate and what made
this so fascinating to me is that no one
is entirely sure why somebody'll because
they the fire department was called and
everything like that with the fire
department got there evidently there was
no fire and had never been so someone
shouted fire for some reason and they're
not entirely sure who it was and over
the years there have been much
speculation as to why someone did that
so one of the most famous are one of the
best-known theories about this and one
that was put forth by Woody Guthrie and
his song that he brought about it was
that a someone friendly to the company
was or like an anti-union person or so
like that was in there they I don't
think they intended to kill anyone
but they were trying to disrupt the
party or like caused a panic
by yelling fire in the crowded room and
there was like a lot of it was kind of
shitty too because like all these people
got killed they did an inquest like the
coroner did an inquest some of the
witnesses that they talked to you know
they were Italian Americans they did not
speak any English and they didn't have
an interpreter there so there was like
some problems in that area a lot of the
witnesses were not asked and they follow
up questions some of the people that
were you know asked to testify hadn't
seen like particular things that
happened or hadn't you know been in
particular places where they were asking
about the coroner ended up giving a
ruling that did not give a cause of
death for a lot of people which they
thought was very odd
now they you know a little while later
like a couple months after the incident
there was a subcommittee committee in
the US House of Representatives that
they they came out there and they were
gonna do their own investigation
they had like they questioned a bunch of
the the witnesses and stuff like that
they were actually given interpreters
this time they had 20 different
witnesses now they had eight different
witnesses at this particular inquest
that said and this is where the whole
like the guy was like a anti-union
saboteur or whatever eight witnesses
said that the person that yelled fired
that they had seen him and they didn't
know who he was but that he had a
citizen's Alliance button like on his
coat which was citizens Alliance was
kind of like a company friendly type of
like you know one of their things that
they kind of did out like breath
strikebreakers and stuff like that so
eight people saw somebody with that
button then he was yelling fire in the
room another thing too is that and this
is a they're not really sure this is a
little bit of a urban legend I guess but
over the years and I think even the
memorial that's still in Calmette
Michigan now says this is that a lot of
the problem happened because the doors
opened inward rather than outward and
that when everyone was trying to get out
they thought the doors opened outward as
they should have and so they couldn't
get out there was also some urban
legends too that someone was on the
other side of the door like keeping
people from getting out how well I've
seen photographs
apparently photographs of the building
and it does appear that the doors opened
outward as they were supposed to and I
think pretty much every investigation
now there's some confusion because
they're like well what could have
happened was that there was like a there
were the outer doors did open outward it
appeared from the photographs and
everything and the blueprints however
there was like a vestibule type of thing
so there was like another set of doors
like further in and it could be those
that opened inward rather than outward
and maybe that's what was causing the
issue however like like I said there
were there were laws in place that say
you know your doors had to open outward
just for this very reason so there was
kind of like some controversy about that
but it does look like the doors opened
outward and it just appeared that
everyone was just trying to run for this
one narrow staircase because they didn't
know about the ladders on the outside
windows and stuff like that so as
everyone you know it's 400 people all
trying to race toward one area and they
ended up you know kind of stepping on
each other and stampeding as I said
there did not appear that there was a
fire because the fire department was
called they did come there and there
apparently was no fire and like I said
I've seen photographs of you know there
are a lot of photographs online you can
find them I found a whole bunch of them
of the funeral and like of the memorial
that happened after the incident and
they showed a picture of the Italian
Hall with the flag at half-staff and
everything like that and it looks
totally fine it looks totally intact so
you know so there's like a whole thing
about that so they're not really sure it
might have been just did everyone
panicked and stuff but the thing that
that just made this really interesting
to me that it was that somebody yelled
fire in that crowded room and they still
don't know who it is now a book that
came out fairly recently like probably
in the last decade or so the person that
wrote this book said I mean they had
done this like extensive investigation
on the case and everything like that and
they think they know who it wasn't they
are correct and saying it was someone
from the citizens alliance which was
like an anti you know a company friendly
like anti-union type of thing in like
the day like I said I'm not saying that
anyone said that they specifically
thought they were going to kill 73
people in this but they were just trying
to like disrupt the party or cause a
panic or cause some kind of problem you
know I mean because all of these workers
were on strike and they didn't like it
so this recent book I don't know what
the person's name was but they said that
they have evidence that they know who
the person was and what their job was
and that they were the person and they
were told to go in there and yell fire
at this Christmas Eve party
and cause chaos like I said it sounds
plausible it does really yeah haven't
like spent part of my high school years
they're known a lot of people from
Michigan you know lived in Detroit for a
couple years I know the culture real
well even back in there even back in the
80s
Michigan is like a [ __ ] really it was
it that the place was dominated by the
auto industry and the unions were very
[ __ ] powerful unions and organized
crime you know there's all kinds of
movies about it you know this goes into
the Chicago you [ __ ] like that too
it's all the kind of like that same
culture it's a weird culture it's a
culture that's kind of like a half
American and half Soviet imagine if the
[ __ ] America was the Soviet Union it
always kind of had a Soviet feeling to
it you know everything grey buildings
grey sky gray ground was snow on it it's
all very [ __ ] industrial factories
everywhere in unions so union activity
anti-union and organized crime yell that
[ __ ] [ __ ] badges it was something
like that I kind of feel like because
here's the thing it's like what I mean
there was a very rancorous strike going
on at the Simon land and indeed the
strike didn't even end until April
following this Christmas where this
happened and the strike had already been
going on for five months they were like
at least 9,000 workers from this
particular mining company from different
it wasn't all one mine it was one mining
company that owned a bunch of mines and
so that you know there was a lot of like
bad blood between the the workers and
the management and the fact that they
were having this big Christmas party at
the Italian hall it doesn't really sure
because why would someone L why would
someone just randomly do that I'm not
saying that that's impossible because
people do crazy [ __ ] all the time but I
feel like there had to be a reason
because as I have never seen any
evidence that points to the fact that
there was ever really a fire in there
the fire department found no fire there
was just no evidence of any fire voting
for people who don't know America real
well you know if we have you know
foreigners and stuff people from Europe
the Detroit area Gary which is close to
the ABN a Indiana Chicago this is the
kind of like the Siberia the Rust Belt
yeah it's like the Siberia of the United
States and it's it was very much where
every
thing was being manufactured like tanco
grad the equivalent of tank old grad in
the Soviet Union place where all the
heavy industry was going on
manufacturing cars and trains or just
whatever you know and it was a they had
a lot of money there but the results so
kind of like a lot of would say like
Union slash Bolshevik [ __ ] activity a
lot of [ __ ] riots race riots of
different kinds it was you know it was
an area of creation and destruction you
never could tell it was going on and of
course the mob was involved in a lot of
that there's there's a lot of different
kinds of Bob's the union was mob the
local government was kind of mob so you
know everything was about playing a
political situation off of something you
know it was a bunch of different
conflicting forces you know wherever
there's money there's gonna be people
fighting over it so this kind of sounds
like if that's what the investigation
said I probably would give some credence
to it that sounds plausible I imagine so
I mean it really does seem to me that
there had to be a reason like I said I'm
not going so far as to say that this
person that was tasked with going in
there and yelling fire I don't think
that they could foresee that 73 people
most of which were children would die
but in a way you know in a way they
probably should have first seen that I
mean that's like super super
irresponsible yeah there was a lot of
different you know union-busting and
then there was strike busting it was you
know it was yeah so I was [ __ ] warfare
and head of hair yeah yeah clearly and I
mean I I definitely think there was some
manner because I really find it hard to
believe that in that situation that
somebody would just wander in there and
just do that randomly just for shits and
giggles yeah because that seems like a
[ __ ] up thing to do especially like in
the middle of a Christmas party when
there are so many children present like
I said I'm not saying they intended to
kill 73 people but that's what ended up
happening and I'm not really sure if
they're ever gonna find out who this
person
is like I said Woody Guthrie wrote a
song about it called 1913 massacre it's
funny it's not it's not really all that
well-known I guess but I found it like
on some random list of horrible [ __ ]
that happened at Christmas time and then
like I worked it looked it up and has a
Wikipedia page now apparently there was
a what I was talking about before there
was his book that came out that I think
the first edition of it came out in 2006
and it was called death's door and it
was about this and in the first edition
of the book he said he thought that it
was like one of those citizens Alliance
people that came in and yelled fire but
he didn't name who it was but in the
newer edition of the book which came out
in 2013 he actually did name the person
and what their job was and he had like
evidence to back it up so it looks like
maybe that that's probably what happened
that people's like a conception about
that it was done on purpose are probably
correct yeah if you guys want to see
some spooky [ __ ] go on YouTube and go
look at the ruins of Detroit and Gary
Indiana which is all kind of like the
part it's the same area you know it's
all part of that same system even though
that's an Indiana garius but and there's
even certain cities in Ohio that are
kind of creepy it's a dead culture now
[ __ ] it was just weird well you know
not a lot of manufacturing know it's all
gone anymore it's all gone but that's
where it all took place there were these
huge churches that are abandoned huge
subway systems that are now abandoned
factories just you know it was another
world back in there was millions of
people there you know making money
mansions that are gone you could even
find Mike Tyson's old mansion that he
abandoned and sold back in the 80s
that's up outside Detroit I really I
like those like urban exploration
channels that go to these like mansions
that are just like abandoned of the
military or something so they still like
furniture and [ __ ] people don't even
shake take the stuff with him he used to
live on 2nd West Hancock and he used to
live in another place just across the
street from there's you know before I
went into the army and [ __ ] that was
like the era where Detroit was like
something out of the movie The Crow
that's why the crow was look as
you know the mean you had you had cool
goth clubs like [ __ ] City Club and
the shelter scene Andrews Hall used to
have [ __ ] Sisters of Mercy playing in
it it was it was another era it's all
God now yeah yeah you know it was creepy
though more New York than New York all
the shit's gone now [ __ ] edge of the
city just cannibalized itself yeah
everybody moved away so the next thing I
want to talk about and this is pretty
horrible also this also happened at a
Christmas Day this happened in 1929 this
is known as the Lawson family massacre
this happened in German ttan North
Carolina Charlie Lawson apparently had
been married to his wife Fanny for 18
years and over that time they had eight
children four sons and four daughters
now one of their kids who was the third
kid William he had died in 1920 you know
when he was still little but the other
seven children were still alive however
on Christmas morning 1929 Charlie for
some reason decided he was gonna wipe
out pretty much his entire family they
were actually sharecroppers they had
been working for a long time they had
finally just two years prior had saved
up enough to buy their own farm so you
know they had their own farm it was
pretty nice and everything like that now
not too long before this particular
Christmas Day Massacre the whole family
had gone into town to buy all new
outfits and to get a family portrait
taken which I have and I will show you
the last portrait taken of this family
before they were all wiped out only a
few days later so look at this picture
and think of that before all dead a few
hours later it's like super creepy so
now they were I mean even though they
owned a farm they had been sharecroppers
so they were still you know fairly poor
they weren't like wealthy or anything
like that so buying new clothes and
getting a portrait taken that's kind of
like a big deal and it wasn't really
something that a lot of working-class
people did
so many people have speculated that
Charlie Lawson was like already planning
to kill his whole family and he went and
got him all these new duds and like a
new picture just so he would have
something to remember them by or to
memorialize them or something because it
was like only like right before he
decided to do this like right before he
did it that he went and the whole family
got photographed so Christmas afternoon
two of Charlie Lawson's daughters Kerry
and Maybelle who were 12 and 7 years old
were going off to visit their aunt and
uncle while they were leaving the house
Charlie was like laying in wait for them
by the barn and when they walked past
him he shot them both with a shotgun
from close range then he bludgeoned them
to death making sure that they were dead
hi there little Pookie she decided to
come join us for the show it's the crisp
do you want the Christmas hat on put the
Santa hat on you want to put the Santa
hat on she's like okay she doesn't mind
at all let's take that all right so yeah
so he shot two of his daughters and then
bludgeon them apparently to make sure
that they were dead then he stowed both
of their bodies in the tobacco barn
after he did that he walked back to the
house his wife was on the porch and he
shot her as well then he one-by-one
tracked down his other four children and
shot all of them starting with his 17
year old daughter Marie then his son
James it was for his son Raymond who was
two and then he beat to death his four
month old baby Mary Lou now for some
reason he also had a 16 year old son
named Arthur now before he had started
killing everyone
he sent Arthur off into town
run an errand although no one is certain
as to why he decided to spare this one
kid and he was like [ __ ] and wiping out
the rest of them this has already sound
familiar to me this is yeah it's a
pretty famous massacre well I was
thinking about that other guy this is
more back in the 80s who killed his
whole family and then started a new life
yeah and he didn't do it out of malice
he did it because he could no longer
support them yeah I'm not sure what some
[ __ ] like that yeah kind of like an
honor kill him but we'll find out more
about it yeah so after he had killed
them all except for Arthur who was
presumably still in town and didn't know
it was going on um Charlie he posed all
their bodies like they he laid them all
down crossed their arms and then put
rocks under their heads like pillows
then he took off into the woods and hung
around in the woods for several hours
and then shot himself in the head hmm so
it was sense it was several hours
between the time that like you know that
he had killed his family in between the
time that he had shot himself like in
the interim like people had found his
family's bodies like before they figured
out where he had gone so when all the
neighbors were like on his property and
they were like [ __ ] freaking out
because they found all these bodies and
they heard the gunshot like from the
woods so they knew that Charlie and then
they went and found him now no one is
entirely sure why Charlie Lawson decided
to Massacre pretty much his entire
family one of the legends that was going
around at the time was that he had
gotten a head injury a few months prior
and that for some reason this had caused
some kind of brain damage and then like
kind of made him flip out and everything
like that although apparently they did
an autopsy after he died and didn't find
any brain damage um some people also
speculated that he wasn't the one who
had done the murders that maybe it was
like some kind of organized crime thing
like it was a mob and they came in and
like wanted to make him look like he did
it or something like that although I'm
not sure if anyone really believes that
but that was kind of another rumor that
was swirling around
and also one of the ones that one of the
legends about why he did it that has
happened that has kind of come about
more recently was that it may have been
that Charlie was having an incestuous
relationship with his daughter Marie who
was at the time 17 years old speculation
was and this is according to talking to
some other like you know relatives like
extended family members and stuff like
that of the Lawson family that they
thought perhaps he had been having sex
with Marie that perhaps she had gotten
pregnant and maybe he was didn't want
everyone to find out didn't want the
pregnancy [ __ ] to come out everything
like that now there is no if there is no
evidence of this I don't know if they
did an autopsy on Marie and found out
she was pregnant or not or I don't know
but like I said some apparently some of
their extended relatives and stuff like
that there were rumors circulating and
apparently Marie allegedly had told some
of her friends that her dad was you know
molesting her and that he had gotten her
pregnant which would provide a motive
that's true but again there's like not a
lot of you know solid evidence for that
conjecture sadly Arthur Lawson who was
16 at the time of the massacre and was
the only member of the Lawson family to
survive he did actually grow up he got
married he had four children
but was killed in a car accident in 1945
at the age of 32 now apparently in
Madison North Carolina there is a place
called the Madison dry goods Country
Store that has a small Museum in it that
is dedicated to the Lawson family that
you can go and visit if you're into that
kind of thing and probably if I was
there I would probably visit that
because that totally sounds like
something I could care to you was there
any evidence any kind of like financial
distress or anything maybe was he losing
his job not that I ever heard of it's
like pretty much the only stuff I've
ever heard of is you know the three ones
I just said either he had a head injury
like a lot of people saw
had a head injury and like that he just
like flipped out because he had brain
damage but like I said they didn't find
any brain damage or that he was
molesting his daughter and that's why or
that he didn't even do it that it was
like some mob thing or he's owed
somebody money and they came and like
wiped everyone out I don't know if I buy
that though because I think even when
like when they found his body in the
woods like where he had committed
suicide
they only saw his footprints it looked
like he had been like pacing around for
several hours like he was trying to
decide if he was gonna do it or not you
know what I mean to me this sounds like
it kind of just matches up with some of
the other homicides I heard about from
from this era it's almost kind of like
an honor killing they had these guys
where they were so uptight about their
role in the family as the family
patriarch that they had to [ __ ] have a
certain kind of job to make a certain
amount of money to keep everybody you
know what I mean to keep the family in a
certain standing that and they just
would not tolerate any kind of setbacks
but yeah anyway so sometimes what
happened these guys would they would
have built a very successful family life
but if they'd lose their job or
something bad would happen to them and
instead of taking a temporary setback in
the income they would kill the family to
save the honor that type of stuff is
very scary to me because that seems like
that's happened I know but that's what
that's what freaks me out is that you
can't just like bat [ __ ] happens to
everybody it's like it sucks but it does
it's like it doesn't mean you're a bad
person or anything like that it's just
you know like I said the universe isn't
different bad [ __ ] happens to everybody
it's like you just you have to roll with
it you can't like if you just have like
a temporary financial sack setback it
sucks I have them all the time but it's
like I never once has it occurred to me
oh I'm just gonna like kill everybody
and burn everything would that why would
that occur to you
why would that occur to happen it's
happened many many I know that's what
frightens me is that a dude thing well
it's a dude thing and it's an old-school
dude that the dude thing and I think
what they were is I think they were kind
of autistics
the autistic maybe to where there was no
been starts they were like well because
functioning Asperger's you know I mean
where they could function they could
make money but they didn't realize that
life was as fluid as it really is and
they expected to get a job and to work
the whole twenty years there and then
collect the retirement there's no
deviation from that so they go to work
for the they go to work for the company
and the company goes out of business and
lays them off and they go well [ __ ] I
can't pay the bills now how how can I
survive as a man how can I afford this
family you know I mean if I can't pay
the bills well I'm not gonna let these
these kids get poor it would be a
dishonor yeah so imma kill everybody
because that's obvious I think yourself
yeah like it's just death before
dishonor it is I guess but it's like
it's just like the weirdest thing to me
because it's just been in Japan all time
well no I mean Ivan happens a lot here
to you it's like it's just like I've
heard of that kind of [ __ ] happening but
it's like it's just it that's just
really not that's nothing that would
occur to me that's nothing that would
well it kind of came from strict
upbringing you know I mean it like I
said it happens in Japan
yeah at the time or at least it used to
yeah at the older generation so I think
that's what kind of what you're talking
about here yeah it seems like something
happened
he knew he wouldn't be able to I mean
just he knew you wouldn't be able to
happen to help just I just I can't
understand he kind of sees them as his
creations because he married them and
then brought them into existence by by
birthing them you know or siring them so
therefore they're his responsibility
yeah and it's a patriarch
thing that's what I mean I think that's
kind of like an outgrowth of the man
like owns everything because you're at
up dad he's good now it kind of has a
mentality where everyone who's related
to him even by marriage is somehow his
responsibility yeah and he has to like
tell you what to tell you even Hera
grown-up if you're a grown-ass [ __ ]
man yeah that's
what you're dealing with there CSO like
I said I do not understand that much
neither do I because I because I don't
understand I don't understand I have
never understood my whole entire life I
have never understood the like audacity
of someone yeah that thinks they have
the right yes you tell someone else what
to do
like in their personal life or with
their bodies or what it's like what
where the [ __ ] do you get off like
thinking that you like especially
someone you barely know
yeah or a person that yeah I'm not
related to this [ __ ] doesn't I
mean even or somebody not really even if
I am related to you it's like I'm a
grown-ass person don't tell me what to
do it's like let's it's what I mean it's
like I'm not you know I mean it's like
if I ask you for advice fine but I will
I usually won't because it's like I
don't ask people for advice because
they're not me what the [ __ ] you know
well they don't know I got to figure
[ __ ] out of my head it's an obsolete
thinking even in a christian-based
[ __ ] society is something that's a
little more prevalent in say like Islam
yeah where the older males for some
reason especially like looks like it's
Saudi Arabia
you know man we're old guys think
everybody underneath them in the family
[ __ ] line is somehow under their
command yeah that's what that's what
that's all about see that kind of shit's
crazy to me yeah that's married my
granddaughter so therefore and I don't
like you and you're not fulfilling
certain things I'm gonna kill you yeah I
understand like where well I don't see
where you get off like telling another
grown-ass person what to do I just don't
get it well you've seen it and I think
that's I think this is what they're
talking about
maybe I mean that it that's it sounds
more likely than these kind of
implausible organized-crime did it I
don't think yeah I don't know I don't
buy the organized crime thing I think
it's oh I'm not I'm I'm not saying that
it's not out of it's not completely
impossible that he hadn't like knocked
up the daughter that might be true yeah
but that happened I think more calm I
think that was proud of common and they
he they would have played that off back
then mmm maybe somehow unless he felt
right I sent her to a sanitarium or some
[ __ ] like that
or another generated in a nunnery like
he did when I got her married
quick I love how it's like any any time
a woman did anything like a little bit
deviating further this like well off to
the sanitarium with you or me is what it
killed her or something like that yeah
the whole family and then himself nah
that sounds like some some way he spared
the son though that's kind of what goes
that was he wanted to carry on y'all I
am and then I guess which goes right
along goes right along in in there
unless he was the oldest with the
patriarchy time and I hate to say that
word cuz you got a lot of [ __ ] okie
[ __ ] women run around screaming about
the patriarchy as if that applies to dit
to to today it does sometimes it doesn't
some aspects still mmm I don't know
you'd have to read into it this is what
I would think is what patriarchy is I
don't give a [ __ ] about patriarchy
though well you don't have to cuz you're
a guy it's just it's not patriarchy it's
just the way it is well that's just the
way it is this is the way things are
well not necessarily certain guys are
gonna do certain [ __ ] because their guys
are gonna do it they're gonna do certain
things usually wise patriarchy yeah but
you can't let me clear you can't let
people get away with [ __ ] just because
they're a guy though you because it's
like oh that that's just what guys do so
we have to like let them just do
whatever I don't know no I don't know
the exact thing you're talking about
well I'm just saying in general just
saying that in general use I'm not
allowed to do anything I want to you do
what you want anyway I don't know you're
talking about I'm just saying you know
what no I'm saying I'm not allowed to go
like go out and do whatever the [ __ ] I
want to patriarchy's become like a
[ __ ] buzz word it's you know it's
like a buzz word and most most the time
when they feel that [ __ ] they know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
yeah but like I said it's it's kind of
hard for you to say because you don't I
mean you know turkey you don't have to
worry about it patriarchy happens within
families yeah sort of yeah there there's
other definitions of it too though I can
make any kind of definition I want no
I'm not no no I'm not saying that people
are making it up I'm just saying there's
other definitions of like you know like
dictionary definitions that you just say
that's not you know just because just
because something has one definition
doesn't mean it I just know
I just don't think I know I don't see
the world in terms of [ __ ] rights or
laws or anything like that I I see the
world in terms of ability you know about
I guess I know certain people have the
certain abilities they could just do
things is it right or wrong I don't know
they just [ __ ] did it yeah but that's oh
yeah you know that's not good but like I
said you know so this was some [ __ ] up
in a way I believe in you say in a way I
guess you could say that I kind of
believe that ultimately we might makes
right - cos that's what I see
yeah but that doesn't mean that that's
good though I'm not here to judge okay
here here okay I look at it this way I'm
out there right I see a bunch of [ __ ]
lions and they're running after the
gazelle the gazelle gets away is that
right or wrong yeah but those aren't
people I don't see I don't differentiate
between people and animals the gazelle
gets away so that's good the gazelle
didn't get eaten but the baby Lions got
to eat the next day I see the Lions get
the gazelle and kill the gazelle
I'm sad I'm oh that poor [ __ ] gazelle
but guess what the baby lion got to eat
well yeah I know there's a lot of like
this well see the entire world like that
right well there's a lot of gray area I
mean it's all gray well yeah it is
yeah I'm just saying that there's kind
of you know I'm not a moralizing
[ __ ] right no well I'm not
either but you know I I get what I get
what you're saying but it's like but
it's like obviously this dude who
flipped out and kill yep that's not good
well I'm not gonna say that this is good
or bad you know I'm going to say this is
no I'm gonna sit this is stupid among
many other things it's just more like
stupid because if he did it the way I
think that he did it he didn't have to
do it but he just was dumb after think
he had to that's what we'll see that
that's the thing that's what fascinates
me about this case is that how like ok
let's say for the sake of argument that
okay maybe he was like you know in some
financial trouble yeah so how do you get
from oh [ __ ] I'm in some financial
trouble how am I gonna support my family
- I think I'm just gonna kill them all I
just see
like that's a very very large gap it's
about ego and yeah he was told by his
father yeah I guess that responsibility
to take care of this family and when he
couldn't take care of the family he felt
that he was a failure and instead of
having them having his family suffer by
taking a big blow to the income and
becoming poor peons or whatever he saves
them disgrace by killing them and then
erasing himself because he thinks that's
the way to go well I think that it is
stupid okay it's a huge always I would
all those people done yeah I would have
done it I wouldn't have done it but it's
like and they didn't have any say in it
it's like what you know it's like it'd
be one thing you like Assaf like you're
in a weird cult or something you asked
me hey you want to kill yourself nobody
said yeah it's like nobody for some
reason he didn't ask him for some reason
if it went down that way for some reason
he thought it was his responsibility to
make the decision for them because he
was in charge yeah I mean that's what
that's where your problem arises private
care that's is when you think that you
can know he was in charge decisions like
that for my he was I'm assuming that if
he did it that way and that was the
reason he was told that he was in charge
and he believed yeah and like I said
that's a problem all right now your
[ __ ] ass ain't in charge they hear it
here's what I'm saying here's what I'm
saying you'd be stupid to think that you
were in charge just well you know I mean
yeah cuz a lot of what people do depends
upon their perception of reality and you
know that's why a lot of bad [ __ ]
happens is because some people don't
have a very good perception of reality
it's very eschewed or an immature
version of reality you know like I said
I would have done that well I hope not
no of course not I'm just saying I
should have got everybody together big
family Mises look I lost my job we're
all gonna have to [ __ ] well that's what
a normal person has their own person
would've done but I don't think this
dude was normal that's what a normal
person would do I don't think be like
you know hey we're not having Christmas
this year or hey or something or
somebody you'll have to get a job or
something you would figure something out
right not let not just jump right to
let's kill everybody that's crazy talk
he he must have come from some kind of a
background where he didn't even realize
a situation like that was possible even
though like I said they don't they
didn't strike me as they had been
sharecroppers I mean that they're
generally very poor yes they had I mean
maybe the fact that they had worked so
long and they had saved up enough money
to buy their own farm and so he thought
oh well we saved up enough money we
bought our own farm so now it's gonna be
like all [ __ ] golden from here on out
and then that wasn't how it worked out
so maybe that's what kind of like
flipped him out a little bit is that he
thought he had made it but he didn't
right so maybe that's what it was it was
this was some old-school thinking yeah
okay and he had some old-school
upbringing and I don't think he was all
that normal to begin with well clearly
and he malfunctioned yeah I mean it's a
way of putting it
this is the male version of postpartum
depression and these women are [ __ ]
have that given birth yeah then they
kill themselves like why the [ __ ] did
you kill you I was depressed hormones
and [ __ ]
yeah well that could happen to men too
but it's different but they never call
it that it's funny because they never
realize every time like some like a
woman flips out there was hormones or
she was a period or something but it but
dudes have hormones too yeah but they
don't call them but they never call it
that just like just like I know it
always kills me the way they always say
like women if women are like mad about
something it's like oh so you're getting
emotional they never say that when men
get angle and get emotional that's what
I mean it's like anger is an emotion
yeah you got a [ __ ] on steroids
he'll do all kinds of crazy [ __ ] that's
what is the father's damage but be never
Austral 15 tightest Ostrom that makes me
really mad and that [ __ ] a nut
he's a lunatic yeah 15 times the normal
and testosterone of a man and he wants
to fight and [ __ ] everything yeah that's
what let's see that's that's the kind of
[ __ ] that makes me mad and that's the
kind of [ __ ] it makes me mad because
people don't think about it you don't
think about it you just think about like
a woman gets anger in its own man
who lit the fuse on her tampon or
whatever like I said it but it's like a
man gets like all mad or AG and [ __ ]
nobody like blames it on his period it's
like you know - or nobody blames it on
his hormones even though that's what it
is yeah it's the same thing yeah but
it's like that testosterones of a drug
like for some reason it's like only
women are emotional I don't get that
I remember it was Vela I remember what
it was like to be 13 14 15 that's what I
mean some hormones right there babe
that's a bad [ __ ] and like and honestly
I've I mean in my personal experience um
I have men in general and the length not
everybody obviously so don't like the
you know flip out men in general are
more emotional more moody you know more
jealous yeah like they have like a lot
more extremes of emotion than women have
with so to me it's very funny that women
get kind of like [ __ ] on for being like
emotional or zoo you know I'm just
saying like in general like how they
kind of like call women out for that
like and he's like a woman gets angry
they're like oh she's getting all [ __ ]
you Mews you could own like on the rag
or whatever it is it no no that's okay
so that's just something that a lot of
people say but it's like it's funny that
but most women I know are not are pretty
even keel most of time I think most of
the time it's like they don't you don't
get too many like shrieking prison well
I don't hang out with any chicks like
that anyway I don't know anybody like
that not really I have I mean I've known
people like that but they're not friends
of mine because I don't like that either
it's like a pure drama over there please
male or female it's like I don't want
somebody around that they got a lot all
the time vocal fry [ __ ] shakes oh oh
they got a lot of that yeah but like I
said I don't I don't hang out but you
know I don't hang out with people like
that so I don't really know I mean
pretty much every chick I've ever been
friends with it's been like normal well
this dude here I don't think this [ __ ]
was all that [ __ ] sound to begin with
and something went wrong in his life and
he would to save the honor of his family
he decided he was gonna take them out
yeah there have been other cases like
that where yeah
the a similar thing happened I think he
thought he was gonna lose the
house or something yeah and he came from
a background where he thought it would
be a natural progression to move forward
that there was no moving back and yeah
cuz there was gonna be a setback he
couldn't deal with that yeah everybody
had to go well like I said maybe he'd
working very hard to raise money to buy
the farm and he's not yeah and I get
that and he left the oldest son survived
to continue on the family line going
back to Adam it was gonna be some [ __ ]
like that yeah well you know cuz of God
yes I'm like that cuz going back to Adam
to carry on so he can reseed and start
again yeah you know it's gonna be
something like that [ __ ] hell yeah so
for the last case here's another case of
a dude who flipped out and killed
several members of him in this case it
was his ex-wife and several of her away
relatives and this is like no well this
is like you know how you like Killer
Santa's okay well this is another one of
these now this is very this is quite
recent this only happened in 2008 this
is known as the Covina massacre and this
happened on Christmas Eve of 2008 Covina
is in the suburbs of Los Angeles
California nine people were killed
either by gunshot wound or by arson
because the dude [ __ ] burned the
house down is those 2008 okay or a
combination of the two things this
happened at a house at one one two nine
East Knoll Crest Drive where there was a
Christmas Eve party going on the
perpetrator of the massacre was a 45
year old man named Bruce Pardo he was
sick of that [ __ ] he entered the house
wearing a Santa suit and started opening
fire yeah [ __ ] Christmas yeah this is
[ __ ] up they made a movie about this
later on to called silent night all
right but like I said you see this
horror movies about killer Santa's that
[ __ ] happens and it happened in this
case so yeah so it's about 11:30 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time on Christmas Eve
Bruce comes into the house wearing a
Santa Claus suit he not he knocks on the
door this was his ex-wife's parents
house this is
former in-laws so he knocks on the door
they were having a party there was about
25 people inside he had in his hands he
had like a gift wrapped like a present
inside the present was a homemade
flamethrower okay yeah cool it not cool
homemade flamethrower yes cool and he
also had two nine-millimeter
semi-automatic handguns he had two
additional nine-millimeter
semi-automatic handguns for on his
possession yeah these were like in his
box he is all about election with him
yeah so he knocks on the door someone
answers he pulls out two handguns and
shot his eight-year-old niece de face uh
he didn't kill her she did live but she
but I mean she had horrible like yeah
yeah she like runs to grip like she knew
who is really girl and be like hey uncle
whatever your [ __ ] name is uncle
Bruce and he shot her in the [ __ ]
face eight years old oh god damn it
I would purify him by fire yeah and then
obviously after the gunshots like
everyone starts running around and
freaking out and then he starts shooting
people in the back damn um then after he
starts shooting then he unwrapped the
Christmas present takes out his [ __ ]
homemade flamethrower
then he which was filled with racing
fuel gasoline okay and set the house on
fire
so as I said nine people died from
either like the gunfire cuz he was just
like spraying bullets everywhere like
died from gunfire or died in the fire
like from the flames or the you know
smoke inhalation or a combination of the
two things three others were wounded the
eight-year-old girl that he shot in the
face it was his niece she survived but
she had very severe injuries a 16 year
old girl who he shot in the back and a
20 year old woman who was trying to get
out of the house she jumped out of the
second-floor window and broke her ankle
there was actually one survivor over the
massacre he went to he jumped out of the
window and went to the neighbor's house
and called you know called 9:1
it took 80 firefighters an hour and a
half to extinguish the blaze the house
was completely demolished I said about
him I saw a picture of it he actually
ran away and went to his brother's house
this is what happened so after this
happened
he took off changed out of the Santa
suit got into his rental car and then he
drove to his brother's house which is
about 30 miles away and shot himself in
the head yeah his brother was not home
at the time
now they thought that initially that he
was going to flee the country because he
had like an airline ticket to like an
Air Canada like airline ticket but what
happened that like the flight itinerary
it was gonna it was on Northwest
Airlines it was supposed to go from Los
Angeles to Moline Illinois because I
guess he had friends or family there but
there was supposed to be a layover in
Minnesota and apparently he had high
school friends in this place in Illinois
and he had called them a few days before
and said he was coming to visit so they
didn't know if he was actually planning
to go there or if that was just like
some kind of ploy I bet you he didn't
yeah like they thought they weren't
really sure they said well he might not
a good way by doing that right right
right so but he had visited these
friends like a couple months prior to
the massacre yeah so it's one report and
this says this on the Wikipedia page it
says the Santa suit during the
flamethrower portion of the attack I
don't know who wrote this Wikipedia page
but that turn of phrase just like amused
me and horrified me at the same time the
flamethrower portion of the attack
during that the parts of the Santa suit
had adhered to his skin so not all of it
could be removed is it melted up on him
yeah because he had like a bunch of heat
when they found him like dead he had a
bunch of third-degree burns on his arms
that's because his flamethrower didn't
work yeah
now when they searched his dead body
they found $17,000 in cash wrapped onto
his legs with like saran wrap inside
like a girdle where'd he get all those
money
I don't know dozen times up where do you
put where the [ __ ] do you get $17,000 -
and then you have all this money you can
I don't think I've ever had seventeen
thousand dollars in cash at one time in
my whole entire life do you have all
this money at a wipeout actually I know
I have in a wipeout your ex's family and
escape with $17,000 you got the $17,000
what do you care about the ex-wife's
family for it
see I don't know I mean it's like what
[ __ ] man if I had $17,000 in Kentish man
like why would I [ __ ] care I don't
care how mad I am at you I'm just like
I'm out of here man I got $17,000 by
tomorrow you'll know buddy just like him
could go to [ __ ] Vegas [ __ ] up hookers
and blow for [ __ ] months
that's $17,000 man that's like I said I
was but I've been like years where I
made less money than that yeah that's
like I could live a long time on $17,000
I'm just that no I'm just walk very four
but I'm just saying so he's [ __ ]
butthurt
so he yeah well clearly so he had all
this cash and he had it on him like he
had it strapped on him like with [ __ ]
plastic wrap on a airplane like DB
cooper DB cooper also when they found
his rental car which was parked like a
block from his brother's house where he
shot himself apparently the the rental
car had been rigged with black powder
like to blow up yeah so he'd done that
too they also found at the scene they
found 413 round capacity handguns that
were empty two hundred rounds of
ammunition they had the car they thought
was like a bomb standard like the bombs
go on had to come and blow it up when
they went to search this douchebags
house in Montrose they found five empty
boxes first semi-automatic handguns they
found a Benelli m2 tactical shotgun and
a container for high-octane fuel tank
gasoline and they also found what they
described as a quote unquote virtual
bomb factory in his house yeah so three
of the victims the eventual victims like
I said nine people died three were
wounded three of the victims deaths were
caused by only gunshot wounds four
others died
from a combination of gunshot wounds and
the fire that he had set in the house
two other deaths came just from the fire
yo the wikipedia page says at least 13
children were orphaned after the
massacre like I said this was his
ex-wife says in-laws and like his
extended family like nieces nephews
aunts uncles that type of thing they
were having a Christmas party
oh [ __ ] did they do to him to make him
that man here's the thing okay now this
is one of and like I said dudes and
butthurt man this is what I'm saying
like a dude's getting more emotional
about stuff like that you know in
general it's like Batson happens usually
where this book now issues up the whole
you just deal with it dudes no no I'm
just saying well you don't see a lot of
women doing this type of [ __ ] you know
what I mean when when bad things happen
you don't jump to like I said it's a
very small percentage of dudes I'm just
saying that women went bad that when
[ __ ] like this happens to have bad
things happen with their marriage or
whatever they don't immediately jump to
I'm just gonna kill all these
[ __ ] these it doesn't occur to
you it just doesn't occur to it doesn't
occur to you I'm a dude it doesn't occur
to me I'm just yeah I said it's a very
small percentage but I said it's almost
so you don't see women doing this kind
of crazy
so apparently with this what they
thought the motive was was Bruce Pardo
so a year prior his ex-wife is file had
filed for divorce now a week before the
massacre which was December 18th the
week before Christmas the divorce had
apparently been finalized now they noted
that Bruce Pardo prior to this had no
history of violence no domestic violence
no nothing no criminal record however
several months prior to the massacre in
July he had been fired from his job he
was an electrical engineer they think
that the reason that his wife filed for
divorce is that he had had a kid from a
previous relationship and had not told
his wife about the kid so apparently
that was you know some cause of
contention and I guess you just didn't
like take it anymore apparently also
there was a thing where they had only
been married like a year or two and
apparently he wasn't
she had a couple kids from like an
earlier marriage and he apparently told
her well you have to use your money to
take care of them because he was not
like a team type of guy I guess and he I
guess he didn't want it yeah he's like
well I'm not paying for those are your
kids so you just take care of that
business so that was like some of the
thing too now in June of 2008 which was
about six months before the massacre
occurred there had been they'd gone to
divorce court and apparently Bruce had
to pay almost eighteen hundred dollars a
month for spousal and child support and
so at the time like Bruce was
complaining to all his friends it's like
oh my ex-wife is like taking all my
money and blah-dee-blah
and only a month after that he got fired
from his job for billing false hours
which you're not supposed to do that so
he got fired rightfully so he did have
the support payments suspended like
after he got fired because the court
understood that he didn't have the money
anymore so you know he didn't have to
pay but he also had to pay his ex-wife I
think ten thousand dollars that was like
part of the divorce settlement she ended
up keeping their dog and she kept the
wedding ring which they usually do but
he was complaining because he's like oh
well she gets to live with her parents
which yay everybody wants to do that
when you're [ __ ] um you know she gets
she gets to live with her parents and
not pay any rent and I have to give her
all this money and it's not fair and
wah-wah-wah and then he was like saying
that oh she's going to Vegas and she's
going to restaurants and just like
spending all my money in the audio I
don't see you know like they all said so
apparently they're speculating that
maybe because he had like pissed and
moaned
to his friends that she was taking all
his money and what a bit she wasn't
blahblah and that that was probably what
the motive for it was he did not kill
his ex-wife however I don't believe it
was sure it was her family he wanted her
to be killed pretty much her you know
yeah he went to the parents house dudes
a ho yeah so apparently this was kind of
like even though I hadn't really heard
about this until I kind of went
researching this was a apparently kind
of a cultural
you know kind of a big cultural thing
that happened because there was a lot of
there was a movie in 2012 like I said
that was called silent night that was
basically about a guy who put on a Santa
suit and made a flamethrower and it was
based on this and went around killing
people like a killer Santa movie and
that was based on this and also do you
remember polystyrene from x-ray Spex she
apparently she recorded a song in 2010
that was called black Christmas and it
was about this and then there was also
another song that came out in 2010
called Santa syndrome by the boombox
poets which was also about this case so
apparently this was a fairly well known
I guess in the Kin California even
though I had never heard of it before
now but like I said killer Santa this
was a real kills he put on a Santa suit
and everything and he had a [ __ ]
flamethrower and he wrapped it in a
[ __ ] present he had the guns and the
flamethrower in a present and he came to
the [ __ ] door and did that [ __ ] just
like a [ __ ] horror movie yeah [ __ ]
that dude pretty much all right sorry to
like leave you on such a bummer note but
you know that's it that's what we do
[ __ ] that it's a horror show it's a
Christmas show it's like we do true
crime you know how we do but uh so
anyway we won't wrap up episode 175 our
very long Christmas special hope you
guys enjoyed it and hope you guys have a
very very very happy holiday whatever
holiday it is that you celebrate or if
you don't celebrate one then don't yeah
you tribute on patreon and go you
subscribe share yeah and if you don't
want to do patreon I mean that's cool
too you can go to our blog 13 o'clock
podcast at wordpress.com and there's a
link in the sidebars a little button and
you can go to a PayPal account if you
would like to give a one-time donation
to the show like some of our other
people have done around this Christmas
season is much appreciated and that it
will do it for our 2019 Christmas
special Merry Christmas Happy Holidays
have a Happy New Year we will see you
next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]